chers collègues mesdames messsieurs
général permettez-moi d'abord d'excuser
l'absence du président bourlange
aujourd'hui comme certains d'entre vous
le savent sans doute il accompagne le
président de la République en visite
d'État en Suède jusqu'à ce soir il ne
pouvait par conséquent être parmi nous
ce matin et il m'a fait le plaisir de me
demander d'animer cette table ronde sur
les crimes de guerre les crimes contre
l'humanité la lutte contre l'impunité
dans les conflits modernes qui un un
sujet qui m'est particulièrement cher
ainsi qu'à certains membres du bureau de
la commission et donc dans ce contexte
de recrudescence des conflits régionaux
et alors que des violations manifestes
de du droit international apparaissent
il nous est apparu opportun
collectivement que nous nous saisissions
de ce sujet
important je vais d'abord souhaiter la
bienvenue aux intervenants et ensuite je
ferai quelques mots de d'introduction
pour brosser le contexte c'est les
attendus de nos échanges donc mesdames
et mon Général permettez-moi de vous
présenter donc j'ai à mes côtés madame
Aurélia dev vos vous êtes magistrate
vous avez été la chef du pôle de lutte
contre les crimes contre l'humanité
crimes et délit de guerre auprès du
tribunal judiciaire de Paris vous avez
notamment à ce titre supervisé l'enquête
de l'ONU sur le financier du génocide
rondais Félicien Kaboua en 2020 et je
peux témoigner de ce professionnalisme
puisque nous nous sommes rencontrés au
Rwanda en
2019 vous avez 10 ans d'expérience à ce
pôle vous venez de publier un livre de
témoignage intitulé crime contre
l'humanité le combat d'une procureur et
vos analyses et éclairages seront
particulièrement pertinents et utiles
pour nourrir notre réflexion
d'aujourd'hui merci de du temps que vous
nous
consacrez madame giseline douset quant à
vous vous êtes conseillère juridique
princi principale à la délégation
régionale du CICR Comité international
de la Croix-Rouge nous savons tous ici
le rôle que joue le CICR dans la mise en
œuvre et le respect du droit
international humanitaire nous l'avons
évoqué encore la semaine dernière
lorsque nous avons restitué notre
déplacement à New York aux nations-
Unies où nous avions rencontré le
représentant de du
CICR votre organisation est souvent l'un
des rares interlocuteurs acceptés par
les belligérants comme la mon sa
participation à la Libération d'otage du
Hamas ou encore son action dans le cadre
du conflit
ukrainien vous êtes donc la
représentante d'un observateur direct
des violations du droit international
humanitaire d'aujourd'hui et votre
appréciation sur le sujet nous sera elle
aussi très
précieuse enfin général Jean-Philippe
rêan vous êtes le directeur de l'Office
central de lutte contre les crimes
contre l'humanité et les crimes de haine
donc l'acronyme OC ch office central de
lutte contre les crimes contre
l'humanité et les crimes de haine cet
oclch a été créé en 2013 c'est une unité
spécialisée pour enquêter sur les crimes
les plus graves cet office est composé
de 40 gendarmes enquêteurs et a
notamment pour mission de diligenter des
enquêtes à l'étranger dans le cadre de
l'entraide pénale internationale de
traquer les criminels en fuite recherché
par les autorités judiciaires
internationales et de constituer le
point de contact de la France pour les
échanges dans le cadre de la coopération
policière
internationale l'Office a été saisi par
le pnat parquet national antiterroriste
de plusieurs enquêtes pour CRIM de
guerre dans le cadre du conflit en
Ukraine et votre expertise assurément
complémentaire de celle de nos autres
invités ne manquera pas de susciter
notre profond
intérêt avant de vous passer la parole
pour 10 minutes chacun je vais
rapidement poser les termes de notre
discussion
je vais d'abord rappeler que bien que
l'interdiction de certains comportements
lors de conflit armés remonte à
plusieurs siècles la notion de crime de
guerre a plus particulièrement été
élaboré à la fin du 19e siècle au début
du 20e siècle à l'occasion de la
codification du droit international
humanitaire qui est également connu sous
le nom de droit des conflits
armés les conventions de adopté en 1899
et 1907 se sont concentrés plus
particulièrement sur l'interdiction
qu'ont des belligérants d'utiliser
certains moyens et méthodes de combat
pour le grand public qui peut-être nous
écoute tout n'est pas permis dans le
cadre de la guerre les la Convention de
Genève de 1864 et les Conventions de
Genève ultérieur notamment celle de 1949
et les deux protocoles additionnels de
1977 en abréger les Conventions de
Genève s'intéresse surtout quant à elle
à la protection des personnes qui ne
participent pas ou plus aux
hostilités donc aussi bien le droit de
laa que le droit de Genève qualifie
plusieurs violations de leurs normes de
crime de guerre mais aucun texte de
droit international ne codifie à lui
seul tous les crimes de guerre on en
trouve une énumération dans des traités
du droit international humanitaire et du
droit international pénal de même qu'en
droit international
coutumier la guerre en Ukraine et les
derniers événements à Gaza ont
brutalement rappelé aux opinions
publiques occidentales une réalité
malheureusement sur de longues dates par
de nombreuses autres régions du monde
que ce soit en Afrique australe en Asie
du Sud-Est ou dans le Caucase les
conflits armés modernes donnent le plus
souvent lieu à des exactions et souvent
à une certaine forme d'impunité pour
leurs
commanditair et pourtant il existe des
instances et des organismes qui
travaillent à la sanction de ces
phénomènes et qui au quotidien essayent
de lutter contre leur reproduction je
pense à la justice au services
enquêteurs des états et à des
organisations comme le CIS
IC cette table ronde vise justement à
vous donner la parole pour toute à la
fois présenter vos contributions à cette
lutte d'une part et essayer d'identifier
les sources de difficultés et de blocage
qui appellent une action diplomatique
résolue de la part de notre pays d'autre
part je voudrais ajouter que la lutte
contre les crimes de guerre et contre
les crimes contre l'humanité n'est pas
qu'une affaire
multilatéral les mécanismes
internationaux attirent le plus souvent
l'attention du public à l'instar des
récentes ordonnance de la Cour
internationale de justice sur la base de
la Convention sur le génocide ou
l'émission d'un mandat d'arrêt contre
Vladimir Poutine par la Cour pénale
internationale mais il n'en reste pas
moins que chaque état a un rôle à jouer
pour punir les auteurs de ces crimes à
travers sa juridiction interne cela
s'exerce notamment mais pas seulement
via la reconnaissance de sa compétence
comme une compétence
universelle la France doit continuer et
y prendre sa part c'est l'objectif de
l'extension de de son champ
d'application acté l'an dernier nous
avions ici même mené une mission
certains doivent s'en souvenir
et ratifier un texte qui permettait de
d'avoir cet échange avec la Cour pénale
internationale ou plus exactement son
mécanisme en Syrie et la suite a été que
le projet de loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de la la
justice pour
2023-2027 a supprimé la double
incrimination qui conditionne donit
auparavant toute poursuite judiciaire et
d'ailleurs mesdames et générales votre
regard sur cet assouplissement nous
intéresse je vais vous laisser sans plus
attendre la parole pour 10 minutes
chacun l'ordre qu'on m'a donné j'espère
qu'il a été négocié avec les
intervenants ça serait à vous la
première madame douset pour rappeler les
grands principes du droit international
humanitair et les constats du CICR dans
les zones de conflit ensuite ce sera
madame Devos et puis le général rêlan
donc madame douset vous avez la parole
pour 10
minutes pouvez y aller ça y est c'est
rouge donc je disais madame la
Présidente je vous remercie merci
mesdames et messieurs les députés de
d'inviter le Comité international de la
Croix-Rouge que je représente ici à à
s'exprimer euh et merci aussi pour les
mots introductifs que que vous avez que
vous avez dit euh peut-être d'emblé je
voudrais dire que certes euh le le droit
applicable dans les conflits armés
qu'ils soient internationaux ou non
internationaux n'est peut-être pas
toujours pleinement respecté et et cela
ne concerne pas seulement les les
conflits que que vous avez cité il
s'agit d'un phénomène ou d'un constat
euh malheureusement récurrent mais ça ne
veut pas dire que le droit international
humanitaire diih quand je parle en
abrégé ne serait jamais respecté et fort
heureusement il y a de nombreux cas de
respect du droit international
humanitaire qui permettent d'éviter des
conséquences désastreuses pour les pour
les populations civiles et qui
permettent par exemple aussi de traiter
convenablement les les prisonniers de
guerre et cela effectivement est dû au
respect par les États de de des règles
du DI mais aussi cela est dû au au
comportement j'allais dire des
combattants qu'il s'agisse de de de
militaires de membres de forces armées
régulières ou de membres de groupes
armés non non étatique
euh et et c'est la raison pour laquelle
partant de de ce constat le CISR s s'est
livré il y a quelques années et il le
fait de manière continue maintenant à
répertorier les cas de bonne application
du DI c'est beaucoup moins facile de de
dire ce qui marche que de dire ce qui ne
marche pas lorsqu'il y a une violation
tout le monde envoit les conséquences
immédiates lorsque ça marche c'est plus
difficile à identifier donc nousous
sommes livrés à à ce à à cela et et
c'est ce qui nous permet en fait de de
le dceler c'est de voir les cas dans
lesquels parce que le DIH a bien été
respecté alors cela a permis d'éviter un
certain nombre de de violations si vous
voulez en savoir plus nous avons dédié
une une base de données
sur notre site internet qui s'appelle
DIH en action et qui répertorie tous ces
cas enfin pas tous mais un certain
nombre en tous les cas puisque c'est
alimenté en en permanence mais qui qui
qui répertorie tous ces cas de bonne
application du DH ce qui a permis
d'éviter des violation pour autant il
est vrai vous l'avez dit que l'actualité
des conflits armés où qu'il se déroulent
ne sont pas exents de violation et on
nous en rapporte beaucoup pour autant
s'agit il nécessairement de crime de
guerre voire de crime contre l'humanité
voire de de génocide comme on a pu
l'entendre affirmer parfois de manière
un peu péremptoire et et même polémique
parfois au sujet de de certains conflits
pas nécessairement et en tout cas ça
nécessite un examen une analyse beaucoup
plus approfondie que simplement regarder
des des des faits et ça cela nécessite
une analyse soigneuse de de ces faits
pour conclure à une qualification pénal
mais mes collègues enquêteurs et
magistrats seront seront vous dire ça
s'agissant du droit international
humanitaire
euh nous pouvons aussi souligner d'emblé
que toutes les infractions au droit
international humanitaire ne sont pas
qualifié d'infraction grav au droit
international humanitaire certaines
infractions que je dirais simples nous
on parle de d'actes contraire au aux
conventions euh ne ne sont pas qualifiés
ou qualifiables pénalement comme on
vient de le dire de CRIM de guerre crime
contre l'humanité ou autres ça ne veut
pas dire qu'on laisse faire les États
dans dans dans ces cas-là en cas d'actes
contraire aux conventions ont toujours
l'obligation de veiller à ce que ces
actes contraires
cessent si on en revient au aux
infractions graves sur un plan
terminologique comme on m'a demandé de
de le de le faire de manière un peu
enfin caricatural sur le s'agissant du
droit international humanitaire que
j'appellerai convention autrement dit
les quatre Conventions de Genève les
protocoles additionnels de 77 comme vous
les avez
cité garde la l'expression infraction
grave uniquement dans les conflits armés
internationaux autrement dit dans les
conflits qui opposent au moins deux
états donc deux ou plusieurs états c'est
vraiment cette cette expression
d'infraction grave est réservé à ces à
ces
conflits lorsqu'on parle je viendrai
après dans les conflits armés non
internationaux il n'y a pas cette même
notion d'infraction grave qui figure
dans le droit international humanitaire
conventionnel pour revenir aux conflits
armé internationaux et la liste des
infractions graves que je ne vais pas
pouvoir vous énumérer évidemment ici ce
que l'on peut retenir c'est qu'il y a un
Tron commun qui figure dans les quatre
Conventions de Genève je dis bien quatre
parce que souvent on entend dans les
médias la Convention de Genève non il y
en a quatre la première je le rappelle
vite fait qui protège les militaires
blessés et malades dans les armées en
campagne donc autrement dit pour les
conflits armés terrestres la seconde la
même chose mais on ajoute les naufragés
c'est pour les conflits armés sur mer la
troisième c'est celle que tout le monde
connaît bien c'est celle relative au
prisonnier de guerre la 4è sur les les
personnes civiles donc ces quatre
conventions qui ont une disposition
commune pour les infractions graves donc
il y a Tron commun toutes les
infractions graves sont celles qui sont
commises en fait contre des biens euh
contre des person personn pardon civiles
ou contre des biens civils et ensuite
s'agissant de la convention 3 et de la
convention 4 il y a un certain nombre
d'autres infractions considéré également
comme grave qui sont spécifiques aux
prisonniers de guerre ou spécifiques aux
personnes aux personnes civiles par
exemple pour les personnes civiles on
trouve dans la 4e convention comme
infraction grave la déportation la
détention illégale la prise d'otage
c'est une énumération qui a été complété
en 1977 par le Protocole additionnel 1
et il est donc le protocole complète he
il ne supprime pas ce qui a été écrit en
en 49 et le protocole 1 précise d'une
part que toutes les attaques contre le
personnel sanitaire religieux médical
humanitaire sont également considéré
comme des infractions graves au droit
international humanitaire et par
ailleurs il reprend à son compte un
certain nombre de d'infractions vous les
avez cité tout à l'heure madame la
Présidente qui sont anciennes celle de
qui est de 1899 et 1907 pardon ce qu'on
appelle les infractions relatives à la
conduite des hostilités donc le
protocole additionnel 1 les reprend ce
qui fait qu'au final si on veut être un
peu plus simple on peut dire que les
infractions graves regroupe à la fois
des infractions commises contre des
personnes civiles et des biens civils
même s'il n'y a aucun préjudice direct
subi et que par ailleurs il y a les
infractions à la conduite des hostilités
qui elles en revanche sont conditionnées
d'une part à l'intention des des auteurs
et d'autre part au préjudices qui sont
subis c'est pas exactement la même chose
mais je pourrais y revenir si vous
voulez donc ce que l'on constate c'est
que encore une fois du point de vue du
DI conventionnel on ne retrouve pas ce
même type de fraction dans les conflits
armés non internationaux et
essentiellement parce que à l'époque de
l'élaboration des conventions 49 puis du
protocole 2 de 77 les états n'avaient
pas véritablement envie j'allais dire
qu'on s'occupe de leurs affaires
internes pour autant tant l'article 3
commun au Convention de Genève de 49 que
le protocole 2 liste un certain nombre
de garanties fondamentales les les
atteintes portées à la vie les prise au
tâ les atteintes à la dignité des des
personnes et l'évolution des pratiques
mais aussi de la des pratiques des états
j'entends mais aussi de la de la
jurisprudence qui s'est vraiment
développé ces dernières années font que
on parle dans les conflits armés non
internationaux pour à peu près le même
type d'infraction de violation grave au
droit international humanitaire ce qui
fait que sur le plan terminologique si
on parle de violation grave cela englobe
les infractions qui sont commises tant
dans les conflits armés internationaux
que non
internationaux dans les étude de droit
coutumier qui qui a été publiée par le
CICR mais qui a été construite pas seule
avec les avec le le concours d'experts
gouvernementaux universitaires et cetera
sur le plan de la qualification de ces
violations le protocole 1 l'avait déjà
dit mais le l'étude de droit coutumier
est valable encore une fois pour quelle
que soit la nature du conflit euh on
considère que les violations graves du
droit international humanitaire sont des
crimes de guerre pour pour autant c'est
une qualification dont je dis souvent
qu'elle est générique c'està dire
qu'elle n'emporte pas une qualification
pénale un crime de guerre au sens du DIH
donc une violation grave du DIH un crime
de guerre au sens du DIH peut très bien
sur le plan pénal soit constituer un
crime de guerre soit être qualifié
poursuivi pour crime contre l'humanité
même pour génocide un exemple très
simple est celui du viol qui a pu qui
est donc un crime de guerre bien sûr
mais qui a a pu être poursuivi selon
plusieurs qualifications pénales euh
comme par le Tribunal pénal
international pour l'exyugoslavie qui
l'a qualifié de crime contre l'humanité
pas de manière systématique mais parfois
et par le Tribunal pénal international
Paul Randa qui est même allé jusqu'à
qualifier l'infraction de génocide donc
ça c'est juste pour montrer que c'est
une qualification générique l'autre
chose dont je voulais dont je voulais
que je dont je voulais parler c'est tout
ce qui concerne la répression
effectivement et la poursuite des
auteurs moi je dirais auteurs complices
commanditair de de crimes de
guerre selon le droit international
humanitaire conventionnel et coutumier
effectivement vous l'avez rappelé euh la
compétence universelle ou en tout dire
en tout cas extraterritorial si on veut
être plus modéré euh et existe depuis
1949 autrement dit on est en 2024 voilà
75 ans que cela a été inscrit dans les
dans les conventions de de de Genève et
euh et comment dire on peut constater
malgré tout que ce n'est pas quelque
chose qui est effectivement complètement
mis en
œuvre oui alors je vais dire deux mots
puis après on pourra revenir sur ça donc
répression donc ça existe depuis 49 il
faut le mettre en il faut le mettre en
œuvre sur les infractions c'est
évidemment toutes les infractions graves
ou violations graves ou pratiquement
toutes il y a quelques exceptions je
pourrais revenir tout à l'heure si vous
souhaité ont été reprises par le Statut
de la Cour pénale
internationale
voilà deux autres choses donc je je
voudrais bien revenir tout à l'heure
peut-être au moment de la discussion
justement sur la lutte contre l'impunité
en France cette fois-ci parce qu'il ne
suffit pas de proclamer l'impunité ou de
proclamer la lutte contre l'impunité
encore faut-il se donner les moyens pour
que cette lutte contre l'impunité soit
effective vous avez rappelé le le
comment dire la la double INCM ation qui
a été levée pour le génocide il y a
quelques temps mais il n'en demeure pas
moins qu'il en reste encore un certain
nombre trois et je veux bien revenir
tout à l'heure il faut absolument qu'en
tant que que que député vous puissiez
agir de tout votre poids pour pour que
ces conditions soient soit levé et puis
ENF dernier mot on a beaucoup entendu
parler notamment au regard du conflit
Hamas
Israël de de d'une certaine polémique
d'un certain affrontement qui aurait
lieu entre c'est un crime de TER
terrorisme c'est pas un crime de guerre
c'est un crime de guerre donc c'est pas
un crime de terrorisme alors je voudrais
vraiment dire avec force que le recours
au terrorisme est interdit par le droit
international humanitaire il faut que ce
soit très clair c'est le recours au
terrorisme est interdit en temps de paix
en temps de guerre lorsqu'il est commis
dans le cadre d'un conflit
armé j'entends par recours au terrorisme
la prise d'otage également lorsqu'il est
commis lorsque ces infractions sont
commises dans le cadre d'un conflit armé
cela constitue à minima un crime de
guerre c'est une violation grave du
droit international humanitaire cela ne
veut pas dire que ça ne pourrait pas
constituer parallèlement une infraction
à la législation pénale nationale
relative à la lutte contre le terrorisme
autrement dit un même fait peut donner
lieu à double poursuite à double
incrimination crime de guerre et crime
de terrorisme je veux bien revenir
là-dessus tout à l'heure parce que c'est
une notion un peu compliqué je vous
remercie
beaucoup merci beaucoup madame douset je
pense qu'il est important effectivement
de même si c'est c'est dur de tenir à
distance toutes ces horreurs si je peux
utiliser un terme grand public et de
bien savoir ce qui relève de tel ou
telle qualification pour pouvoir lutter
contre l'impunité je vous remercie je
passe maintenant la parole à Madame
Aurélia de vos pour que vous puissiez
partager votre expérience pour environ
10 minutes et je vous ferai signe
puisque j'ai donné 12 minutes à madame
douset je vous en prie je vous remercie
beaucoup merci beaucoup pour cette
invitation et c'est un plaisir et un
honneur que de pouvoir venir partager
l'expérience qui a pu être la mienne la
nôtre dans la poursuite de de ces crimes
les plus graves je crois qu'avant tout
il est important de rappeler que les
crimes dont nous parlons communément
appelés les crimes internationaux sont
considérés comme les crimes les plus
graves parce que ils vont porter
atteinte et avoir un impact sur la
communauté internationale dans son
ensemble et cela revê à mon sens une
dimension tout à fait particulière alors
sur le plan internationaux sur le plan
pardon pénal ces crimes internationaux
vont s'entendre de ce que Madame dousé
vient de développer les crimes de guerre
constitutifs de violation du droit
international humanitaire et donc
attaché on le comprend très bien à
l'existence d'un conflit armé mais ça se
l'entend également des crimes contre
l'humanité qui comporte au premier rang
de ces crimes le crime de génocide et
qui sont je crois que c'est important de
le dire détachables du conflit armé euh
et qui peuvent commis être commis en
temps de paix ce qui ce qui introduit de
la confusion c'est que souvent ces
crimes sont de commis de manière
concomitante ou à l'intérieur d'un d'un
conflit armé alors la prépression de de
ces crimes se pense dans un premier
réflexe comme de la compétence de la
Communauté internationale communauté
internationale qui a réagi au début des
années 1990 au crime commis en
ex-yugoslavie ou au Rwanda par la
création de tribunaux AD maises
tribunaux qui ont une durée évidemment
limitée dans le temps et limitée dans
l'espace des juridictions mixtes
internationalisées comme au Cambodge
sierraléone ou actuellement en
centra-afrique la Cour Pénale spéciale
de Bangui ont été également pensé pour
impliquer à la fois les États et la
communauté internationale dans une
action collective la Cour pénale
internationale enfin dont on parle
beaucoup bien évidemment entrée en
vigueur en juillet 2002 joue désormais
un rôle dans la poursuite des plus hauts
responsables de ces crimes mais on en
perçoit
inévitablement et il ne faut pas être
juriste pour le percevoir l'apportter
limité dans le temps pas avant 2002 dans
l'espace puisque beaucoup d'États et non
des moindres ne sont pas partis au
Statut de Rome et évidemment dans
l'action puisque l'accès pour la Cour
pénale internationale au territoire est
souvent subordonné parfois au choix de
poursuite partiel euh soumise au choix
du vainqueur en quelque sorte mais le
lieu naturel est souverain et c'est de
cela dont je vais vous parler de la
justice pénale cela reste cela demeure
les États et parce que la France s'est
engagée en adaptant les résolution des
nations- Unies qui ont créé les
tribunaux àoc mais aussi le statut de la
de de Rome qui a créé la Cour pénale
internationale et bien elle dispose d'un
arsenal juridique qui va être sévraé à
géométrie variable pour connaître de ses
crimes alors ATT attention à
l'application dans le temps nous ne
pouvons pas en en France poursuivre des
crimes contre l'humanité ou crimes de
génocide avant le 1er mars 1994 nous ne
pouvons pas poursuivre des crimes de
guerre qui seraient commis avant le 9
août 2010 ni des disparitions forcées
qui seraient commises avant le 5 août
2013 sauf à les considérer comme des
actes sous-jacents de crime contre
l'humanité dans certaines circonstances
alors la compétence classique des
juridictions françaises je pense que
c'est important d'y revenir parce que
elle va va révéler elle-même des aspects
qui sont à mon à mon sens insuffisamment
pris en considération alors l'auteur des
crimes évidemment si les Français quel
que soit le lieu de commission des
crimes peut être poursuivi cela inclut
et c'est important les personnes morales
et il y a un impact désormais je pense
qu'on pourra y revenir important du
devoir de vigilance des entreprises qui
ne peuvent plus désormais arguer ne pas
savoir la nationalité de la victime
quand elle est française bien sûr
entraîne la compétence des juridiction
française et parfois la question des
faits commis en France ça peut paraître
incongru quand on parle de crime de
guerre et de crime contre l'humanité
aujourd'hui mais je souhaite quand même
ouvrir la porte sur un point particulier
sur la dimension financière de ces
crimes le financement de ces crimes tout
d'abord qui n'est pas pris en compte en
tant que tel dans notre code pénal il y
a pas de poursuite possible pour
financement des crimes contre l'humanité
et financement des crimes de guerre
c'est à mon sens un vide juridique cela
ne peut être poursuivi que sous la forme
de complicité par aide ou assistance
fourniture de moyens tout cela est très
compliqué à démontrer le blanchiment du
produit des crimes là encore manque de
compétences légales suffisant et
d'intérêt de nos services de
renseignement financier qui se
concentrent uniquement sur la sur le
financement ou le blanchiment dans le
casadre du terrorisme la question des
armes qui sont des fournitures de moyens
l'imitation là encore de la législation
sur les trafics d'armes qui
insuffisamment prend en compte la
dimension de lien avec les crimes
internationaux
de la même manière la traite des êtres
humains qui peuvent être constitutif de
CRIM contre l'humanité qui est
insuffisamment pris en compte quand elle
se propage sur le territoire français
alors au-delà de ces compétences
classiques qui révèlent ces difficultés
la compétence universelle on en a parlé
poursuivre en France des étrangers qui
ont commis des crimes à l'étranger sur
des étrangers alors bien sûr un certain
nom de convention qu'on a adapté sur la
torture les disparitions forcées les
tribunaux adoc et Statut de Rome vont
permettre d'absor
une compétence universelle avec des
critères différents selon les crimes
mais attention toujours avec un lien de
rattachement et je crois que c'est
important et de mon expérience de
procureur il me semble que ce lien de
rattachement il est essentiel qu'il soit
une présence en France ou une résidence
habituelle selon les cas il me semble
que c'est important pour plusieurs
raisons tout d'abord la légitimité de
l'action de la justice française à mon
sens provient de l'idée que nous ne
devons pas constituer un refus
pour des criminels de guerre ou des
auteurs de crimes contre l'humanité donc
ça implique évidemment une présence ou
une résidence et c'est de cela don qu'on
tire cette légitimité l'efficacité aussi
parce que de ce lien de rattachement va
permettre ce lien de rattachement va
permettre une prise sur l'auteur des
faits à défaut d'avoir une prise parfois
sur le lieu de commission de ces faits
et donc de l'efficacité de la légitimité
vont euh ressortir la possibilité
d'aboutir et je crois que c'est très
important parce qu'une poursuite ou une
enquête qui n'aboutit pas dans ces
domaines là c'est le renforcement en soi
de l'impunité il faut mieux parfois ne
pas faire que de faire mal ou de ne pas
faire jusqu'au bout et on pourrait en
reparler au regard des moyens qui sont
dévolu à ce contentieux en France alors
pour évoquer on pourra évoquer la la
double incrimination peut-être dans le
casadre de la discussion face à cette
complexité il fallait bien sûr des
magistrats et des enquêteurs spécialisés
c'est le cas depuis la loi du 13
décembre 2011 pour le pôle crime contre
l'humanité crime et deslit de guerre qui
rentre en vigueur en janvier 2012 qui a
une compétence nationale concurrente et
l'Office central dont vous parlera le
général Rayan alors ce pôle c'était une
section du parquet de Paris au même
titre que la section
antiterroriste ces deux sections ont été
extraites du parquet de Paris en juillet
2019 pour constituer ensemble
aujourd'hui le parquet national
antiterroriste à ce jour si procure
trois juges d'instruction je vous
noterez que trois juges d'instruction
aujourd'hui en 2024 c'est la même chose
qu'en 2012 c'était aussi trois juges
d'instruction pour 20 dossiers sur le
Rwanda en 2012 90 dossiers à
l'instruction sur de nombreuses zone en
2024 il n'y a pas eu d'évolution des
effectifs des enquêteurs on en on en
parlera avec le général ran qui a mon
sens sont en nombre insuffisant et la
compétence de la Cour d'assise de Paris
il y a aujourd'ui aujourd'hui beaucoup
de dossiers le Rwanda la Syrie le
libériia la République centrafricaine la
République démocratique du Congo
l'Ukraine près de 190 procédur enquête
préliminaire et information judiciaire
confondu les actions du pôle depuis plus
de 10 ans
c'est sont des des pistes que je lance
pour la discussion le développement des
réseaux de coopération le réseau
génocide européen l'Union européenne
Eurojust mais aussi toute une nébuleuse
d'acteurs non étatiques société civile
ONG agence des Nations Unies commission
d'enquête et mécanisme des acteurs qui
ne sont pas naturels pour le magistrat
et que je crois que nous avons réussi à
instauré comme une nouvelle manière de
de travailler et de procéder première
équipe commune d'enquête en matière de
crime contre l'humanité avec les
autorités allemande sur la Syrie premier
procès sur le pour génocide pour crime
de génocide en France depuis SEP
personnes ont été jugées Rwanda ou
Liberia la Syrie est à venir je crois le
développement ou le début de
développement d'une conscience dans
l'institution judiciaire beaucoup reste
à faire à mon sens tentative également
de développement d'une synergie en
France et j'y reviendrai de nombreuses
enquêtes et une lecture audacieuse des
textes qui constituent les procès et les
avancées dont on voit le résultat
aujourd'hui et le développement
d'enquête d structurelle que je pourrais
également développer dans la discussion
pour avoir une vision globale des
situations afin de caractériser les
contextes dans lesquels les crimes sont
alors de mon expérience à la tête de ces
poursuites pour conclure pendant de 10
pendant plus de 10 ans je retiens en
bilan une réflexion que je souhaite
partager avec vous et qui constitue à
mon sens un paradoxe fondamental il y a
à la fois des avancées qui ont été
considérable mais aussi des fragilités
qui demeurent très importantes les
avancées c'est bien sûr la création de
structures le pôle l'Office qui sont en
soi je le dis remarquables et d'une
certaine manière inédite dans leur
complétude par rapport à nombre de pays
on a chez certains uniquement des
procureurs spécialisés mais pas de jug
d'instruction parfois des enquêteurs
mais pas de procureur là on a une
structure une structuration de
l'ensemble de la chaîne pénale qui est
absolument remarquable et qui existe et
ça il faut évidemment le noter des
enquêtes de qualité audacieuses qui se
sont professionnalisé et une place de la
France sur la scène internationale dans
les réseaux de coopération qui n'est
plus à démontrer à sens mais pourquoi
fragilité parce que il en demeure des
moyens d'évolu au contentieux qui sont
des rais déraisonnablement ridicule je
je je j'utilise fort enfin à dessin un
terme assez fort la conséquence c'est la
dispersion des enquêteurs des choix qui
sont opérés au gré des actualités et de
la médiatisation ce qui ne permet pas
d'aboutir réellement parce que tout cela
se conjugue avec la nécessité d'un temps
long de l'enquête qui va dépasser le
temps politique qui va dépasser le temps
médiatique et ce temps long il obtient
des résultats quand par exemple en
Allemagne vous avez les mêmes enquêteurs
qui ont travaillé pendant 12 ans sur le
cas syrien et qui apporte devant les
juridictions des procès finalisé le
temps perdu parfois qui aboutit à la
mort des suspects encore récemment avant
leur jugement la concentration peut-être
sur le facile et je mets de très gros
guillemets quand même sur facile les
enquêtes Rwanda les enquêtes qui visent
des Français dans des enquêtes dit
miroir qui n'ont pas vocation à aboutir
en France finalement mais qui concerne
des Français victimes à l'étranger
l'attachement à la lutte contre la haine
qui est extrêmement importante mais qui
et qui permet d'obtenir des résultats
immédiats mais qui en réalité pourrait
aboutir à terme à l'abandon de la
compétence universelle et des enquêtes
les plus ardues ceci valant pour les
années à venir la conséquence concrète
c'est la résidence en France de
criminels de guerre et d'auteurs de
crimes contre l'humanité qui ne sont pas
inquiétés par la justice à mon sens
problème de sécurité intérieure on
pourra en discuter et puis les
structures sont fragiles vous aurez noté
que le pôle crime contre l'humanité
disparaît dans la qualification de du
terme derrière le parquet national
antiterroriste et le problème d'un
système qui ne prend pas en compte
toutes les dimensions de ces crimes
alors deux propositions pour conclure
pour l'action publique peut-être
envisager la création d'un pô le crime
contre humananité autonome qui pourrait
fédérer l'ensemble de ces dimensions ou
un parquet national qui viendrait
adjoindre au parquet national
antiterroriste d'autres dimensions de
criminalité organisée de
cybercriminalité d'affaires militaires
euh mais aussi l'autre proposition pour
l'action en la matière et le rayonnement
de la France créer véritablement un
système au niveau national qui permet de
se projeter de projeter la compétence à
l'international d'avoir un poids plus
fort d'envisager peut-être comme
certains pays l'ont fait un ambassadeur
crime de guerre qui puisse porter cette
voix et agir sur le plan national ou un
délégué interministériel ou une mission
interministérielle mais quoi qu'il en
soit un marqueur de volonté politique
pour fédérer les ministère concerné et
le porter à l'international à mon sens
c'est la vision qu' qu' pourrait y avoir
lieu d'avoir je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame Devos
effectivement les les propositions que
vous faites je n'en doute pas feront
l'objet d'un d'un débat et de de
réaction général Jean-Philippe Ran
pouvez-vous nous parler de l'action de
l'Office central de lutte contre les
crimes contre l'humanité les crimes de
de haine l'oclch pendant 12 minutes
environ avec plaisir madame la
Présidente merci pour votre invitation
mesdames et messieurs les députés merci
pour votre attention et désolé pour
cette voix un peu
caverneuse dont je ne suis pas à
laquelle je ne suis pas habitué alors
madame devvos vient vient d'évoquer
le la structuration de de de l'État
français pour répondre à cette
problématique extrêmement importante
l'Office Central que je commande depuis
maintenant plus de 3 ans a été créé en
2013 euh initialement pour constituer
l'instrument adhoc pour le parquet
spécialisé d'abord puis aujourd'hui le
parquet national antiterroriste et son
pôle crime contre l'humanité euh il est
issu historiquement d'une se d'une
division qui avait été spécialement
dédiée à ce contentieux euh au sein de
la section de recherche de Paris qui
avait été habitué au fil des années et
notamment depuis le génocide des TS
Rwanda à prendre en compte un certain
nombre d'enquête dans ce dans ce domaine
mais il y avait eu aussi il y avait eu
aussi pardon euh les affaires Papon
Touvier et d'autres qui avaient permis
aux gendarmes de se familiariser avec
notamment la traque de certains fugitifs
criminels de guerre
euh et puis donc en en en 98 la
signature de de du Statut de Rome a dû
nécessairement euh
entraîner cette cette la création de cet
office central ça a pris un petit peu de
temps puisque comme je vous le disait le
décret signé par le Premier ministre
date de date de 2013 alors il fixe ce
décret l'émission essentielle de de
l'Office Central on a évoqué les crimes
de génocide crimes de guerre et CRIM
contre l'humanité mais la compétence de
cet office centrale se porte aussi sur
les tortures au sens de la Convention
New York de de 84 et sur les
disparitions forcées prévu par la
Convention à laquelle la France est
partie de 2006 euh on a d'ailleurs
ajouté cette cette infraction au
périmètre de l'attribution de des
attributions de l'Office Central lors de
la révision du décret en 2021
euh décret modifiant euh modificatif
pardon afin de de lui adjoindre des
compétences en matière de crime de haine
euh madame Devos évoqué à l'instant ce
ce ce sujet euh c'était une volonté du
du gouvernement que d'avoir un outil qui
soit aussi en capacité de traiter ou de
coordonner l'action des service
d'enquête dans ce domaine qui
était matérialisé à l'époque en 2019
notamment par des infractions graves
commise dans le Grand T de la France et
l'actualité qui s'est poursuivie
démontre peut-être la pertinence de de
de cette réforme et de l'action de de de
cet office centrale dans dans ce
domaine pour autant historiquement et
principalement la mission c'est
évidemment celle de lutter contre
l'impunité des crimes internationaux
selon les critères de compétence de
juridiction française que Madame Devos a
a évoqué et sur lesquel je ne reviens
pas pour ce qui nous concerne euh nous
sommes aujourd'hui en charge de plus de
170 dossiers euh que nous confi le
parquet national antiterroriste et les
juges d'instruction spécialisés ces 174
dossiers pour être précis euh concernent
32 pays
j'ai récemment réorganisé la division du
lieutenant colonel De Jong qui
m'accompagne aujourd'hui en trois
groupes un groupe Afrique qui traite de
80 dossiers un groupe Moyen-Orient qui
est lui en charge de 66 dossiers et un
groupe EUROPE plus parce qu'il a une
compétence un peu élargie qui traite un
peu moins de 30
dossiers évidemment ça fait un nombre
conséquent de de dossiers que nous nous
avons à traiter sous l'autorité des
magistrats et pour lesquels nous devons
évidemment fixer un certain nombre de
priorités nous devons prioriser notre
action dans un certain nombre de de
dossiers et nous le faisons évidemment
euh avec l'aval des magistrats qui sont
les les les directeurs de ces
enquêtes sur la répartition euh de de de
ces dossiers ce qu'il faut que vous ayez
comme information c'est que à peu près
la moitié d'entre eux de ces dossiers
sont initiés par la présence en France
ou plutôt la demande d'asile en France
de
certains de certaines personnes qui se
voient refuser la protection au titre au
visat de l'article 1F de la Convention
de Genève de 1951 c'est-à-dire parce
qu'ils sont suspectés d'avoir commis
dans leur pays d'origine un certain
nombre d'infractions graves euh donc
l'officier l'Office français de
protection pour les réfugi à patride
mèneent des
enquêtes à la suite de ces demande
d'asile et les officiers de protection
sont mettent parfois à jour certaines
suspicis dont ils font part dans le
cadre de l'article 40 depuis 2017 au
parquet national antiterroriste ces
enquêtes que l'on appelle pour faire
simple les enquêtes
1F sont ensuite confiés pour l'essentiel
à l'office central et là débute pour
nous un travail qui est un
travail totalement inversé par rapport à
ce que nous avons l'habitude de faire
faire classiquement en tant qu'officier
de police judiciaire c'est-à-dire que
nous avons donc là la désignation d'un
d'un présumé auteur de d'un crime
international et il nous faut nous
mettre en quête
euh des victimes des témoins de ces
faits et des lieux dans lesquels ces
faits ont été commis des lieux qui
évidemment pour certains d'entre eux
quand on parle d'un réfugié afghan ne
sont pas si faciles d'accès que cela ou
d'un réfugié syrien
euh puisque la coopération
internationale évidemment avec ces pays
ne fonctionne pas et ne permet pas aux
enquêteurs de se déplacer pour aller
rechercher ces éléments de preuve euh
pour les magistrats
voilà une des une des difficultés auquel
nous nous faisons face dans le cadre de
sensiblement la moitié de ces de ces
dossiers que j'évoqué alors certains
dossier avance pour autant puisque nous
avons développé un certain nombre de de
moyens pour essayer de de d'avancer mal
malgré tout dans ces enquêtes qui sont
particulièrement
complexes et et j'y reviendrai sur dans
un dans un
instant il y a une part importante aussi
de l'action de l'Office central qui
mérite d'être cité c'est celle qui
répond aux demandes d'entraide pénale
internationale
entrant en France puisque ce contentieux
est évidemment basé sur la coopération
internationale et nous sommes évidemment
saisis par bon nom nombre de pays et par
la Cour pénale internationale les
autorités judiciaires françaises en tout
cas d'un certain nombre de demandes
d'entraide que l'Office centrale est en
charge d'exécuter et il s'agit pour
l'essentiel d'audition de témoins ou de
de recherche d'éléments de preuve
parfois dans le cadre de l'action de
certaines entreprises ou
sociétés sur le mode de déclenchement
des des enquêtes j'ai évoqué celle
relative au au dossier 1F il y a
évidemment les dépôts de plaintte des
des des victimes qui
peuvent intervenir directement auprès du
auprès du parquet euh qui interviennent
le plus souvent d'ailleurs avec l'appui
d'organisations non gouvernementales euh
qui sont extrêmement précieuses dans
dans dans ce contentieux et qui font
avancer un certain nombre de de de
dossiers nous rencontrons comme je l'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure plusieurs défis
euh celui de l'accès aux zones d'enquête
euh l'Afghanistan la Syrie ne ne
répondent pas euh évidemment au aux
demandes d'ENT pénale international
euh et certains euh autres pays
pourraient ne pas répondre également à
ces demandes dès lors que euh elle
porterait sur des individus qui sont par
exemple proches du pouvoir en place à
l'heure actuelle dans ce dans dans ce
pays euh il y a donc euh euh euh parfois
euh des choix à à faire sur les
orientations qui sont données à
certaines demandes d'entr pénale
internationale puisque souvent dans le
cadre des conflits les deux parties sont
soumis à à enquête et que nous avons
parfois des dossiers qui qui concernent
l'une et l'autre partie et que la France
est appelée à traiter j'allais dire de
façon alternative pour essayer de faire
avancer les
choses par rapport au aux autorités
locales en place il y a évidemment une
chose extrêmement importante pour nous
qui retarde aussi ou qui ralentit ou qui
complexifie le le travail c'est c'est
l'ancienneté des faits qui provoque
évidemment une une grande détérioration
des preuves une altération de la mémoire
évidemment des des témoins et parfois
une
adaptation des
discours ce temps écoulé est
évidemment un obstacle au recueil de de
la preuve
testimoniale car au-delà du du problème
de la prescription qui qui qui existe
malgré tout unique pour les pour les
crimes de guerre en France sur ce sur ce
contentieux ce peut se poser un problème
de mémoire ou de disparition des témoins
les les les dossiers que nous traitons
sont parfois des dossiers extrêmement
anciens bon le plus ancien et relatif à
à la rafle du vieux port de Marseille en
1943 et là on fait un travail quasi
d'historien pour essayer d'avancer sur
sur ces aspects mais évidemment là les
témoins directs de des faits sont sont
sont
disparus dans le cadre de du génocide
des toutsi au Rwanda euh les enquêteurs
se sont rendus sur place depuis plus de
20 ans
euh et parfois donc maintenant ça fait
30 ans euh beaucoup d'individus ont ont
évidemment quitté le territoire où sont
décédés euh et certains sont même devenu
rétiscent à l'idée de témoigner souvent
parce que ils ont parfois été entendus à
plusieurs reprises par différents
enquêteurs de pays différents ce qui est
parfois évidemment un double traumatisme
pour ce qui les concerne
alors sur les techniques d'enquête et je
pense que j'arriverai sans doute au à la
fin de mon propos
euh je je je pourrais évidemment
répondre à à ces questions il y a une
chose sur laquelle je veux je je veux
insister
euh nous n'avons pas de dispositif en
France qui permet de recueillir les
témoignages de victimes ou témoins de
crimes internationaux entrant sur le
territoire national nous avons mis en
place un dispositif spécifique pour les
réfugiés
Ukrainiens après l'invasion de leur pays
de façon à pouvoir fournir via les
autorités judiciaires à la Cour pénale
internationale et à l'Ukraine
d'éventuels témoignages pertinents pour
leurs enquêtes mais il n'y a pas de
systématisation du recueil de ces
éléments auprès des migrants entrant sur
le territoire national de la même façon
qu'on fait pour les auteurs présumés je
pense que là il y a il y a sans doute un
un travail à à conduire pour essayer
d'améliorer cet aspect et puis pour
essayer
de contrebalancer les difficultés que
nous rencontrons avec l'accès au
territoire il y a évidemment des des
techniques particulière que nous avons
tenté de mettre en œuvre et notamment
l'exploitation de l'imagerie
satellitaire il y a là un vrai sujet que
votre commission pourrait évidemment
prendre en compte le secrétariat général
des pour les affaires européennes s'en
est emparé mais nous tentons
d'obtenir du centre satellitaire
européen un certain nombre d'images qui
nous permettrait d'avancer dans nos dans
nos procédures malheureusement nous nous
Lons à la classification de celle-ci qui
nous permet pas de les intégrer dans les
procédures judiciire puisque ces images
sont essentiellement dédiées
à des services de de renseignement je
pense que là il y a alors que l'Europe
s'est réellement mobilisé sur le sujet
notamment pour ce qui concerne les faits
commis en Ukraine il y a là un paradoxe
qu'il me semble pertinent de de prendre
en
compte merci beaucoup général merci à
vous trois mesdames également pour ces
interventions très complémentaires alors
comme je suis la gardienne du temps je
vais avoir un un défi c'est de donner la
parole à tout le monde et que vous
puissiez également répondre donc je
rappelle la règle du jeu euh je la
précise pour vous qui es peut-être moins
familier je vais donner la parole à
chaque orateur de groupe pour une
question de 2 minutes 30 et ensuite vous
aurez en tout 2 minutes 30 pour répondre
donc je vais plutôt vous demander de
lever le doigt à chaque fois parce que
si
chacun pardon si chacun répond on on va
dépasser et ensuite ce sera les
interventions individuelles et nous
devons finir à 12h30 voilà la règle du
jeu et le sujet est absolument
passionnant mais merci encore donc je
donne la parole à Renaissance au
collègue Philippe
guillmard merci madame la Présidente
merci aux intervenants pour nous avoir
exposé les modalités les difficultés de
traitement de ce qui au fond constitue
des des atrocités commises dans dans le
cadre de de conflit les
tragédies du darrefour du Rwanda ou
encore de la la Syrie sont devenus des
des symboles de de ces crimes et et
révèle les les défis inhérents à à la
lutte contre entre l'impunité desfill
qui s'étendent désormais à d'autres
théâtres de de
conflits qui qui sont bien sûr dans dans
nos esprit malgré l'existence de
mécanismes judiciaires internationaux la
Cour pénale internationale on on
constate que leur efficacité est
relative des responsables à l'instar de
l'ancien collaborateur du président
soudanais déchu Ahmed Haroun échappe
encore à la justice tandis que d'autres
attendent indéfiniment un Verdi dicte
cette réalité semble s'encrée dans le
manque d'engagement de certains États en
tout cas je je je je vous soumets cette
question là et dans l'exigence également
de temps et de moyens pour mener des des
enquêtes
approfondies face à cette situation la
France a renforcé son engagement
notamment par deux arrêts historiques de
l'assemblée plainère de la Cour de
cassation qui ont été évoqués tout à
l'heure en date du 12 mai 2023 qui
marque un tournant en intégrant la
compétence universelle dans notre
système juridique et ouvre ainsi la voie
la poursuite de responsables de ces
crimes sur notre territoire avec les
limites je crois madame Devos que vous
avez rappelé tout à l'heure dans cette
décision de de l'assemblée plainiaère il
y a des des des éléments d'information
notamment le fait que 85 enquêtes
préliminaires et 79 instructions sont
ouvertes selon les indications données à
l'audience par le procureur général euh
près la Cour de cassation cette
jurisprudence importante a été consacrée
par l'adoption d'un amendement qui
supprime la condition relative à la
double incrimination lors de l'examen du
projet de loi d'orientation de
programmation du ministère de la Justice
au regard de ces avancées quelles
contributions peuvent à nouveau apporter
nos juridictions nationales pour
garantir que la justice soit rendu même
lorsque les mécanismes internationaux
rencontrent des obstacles c'est je crois
un point madame deos que vous aviez
commencé à à aborder et deuxième point
peut-être
plus qui concerne l'intervention de
madame dousé conditions doivent être
relevées par la loi pour lutter plus
efficacement contre l'impunité je crois
que c'est ainsi que vous finissiez votre
intervention tout à l'heure
merci merci donc 2 minutes 30 parfait et
donc vous êtes interpeller toutes les
deux mesdames vous avez une minute 15
chacune alors
oui merci pour cette question juste un
tout petit point quand même sur les
arrêts du 12 mai 2023 qui sont présentés
comme une avancée
alors moi je dirais plutôt que c'est une
clarification parce qu'en réalité nous
n'avons pas attendu les arrêts du 12 mai
2023 pour avoir l'interprétation qui a
été donnée par l'assemblée pliniiaire de
la Cour de cassation sur la double
incrimination en réalité son c'est
l'arrêt du 24 novembre 2021 de la
chambre criminelle de la Cour de
cassation qui avait eu une
interprétation extrêmement restrictive
qui à mon sens ne répondait pas à
l'intention du législateur euh et qui
allait bien au-delà et qui avait donc un
peu fermé les vannes la conséquence
entre novembre 2021 et le 12 mai 2023
c'est qu'il y a quand même 18 mois en
quelque sorte un peu perdu aussi pour
l'avancée de ces enquêtes parce que et
magistrats et enquêteurs étaient un peu
dans la suspension dans l'expectative
donc c'est une clarification tant mieux
si le législateur aussi vient clarifier
euh son idée mais je crois que dès le
départ il imaginait bien que euh les
faits devaient être poursuivable quelle
que soit la qualification sinon c'était
vidé de son sens ce qu'il souhaitait
alors j'en je ah oui c'est vrai il faut
partager avec voilà simplement juste
pour dire ce qu'il faudrait sur le plan
structurel bien sûr on parle toujours
des moyens c'est pas toujours seulement
les moyens c'est les moyens après il
faut voir ce qu'on en fait et où
effectivement euh euh redonner une place
véritablement à à ce contentieux en en
quelque sorte lui donnant une visibilité
hein et en permettant aussi à mon sens
de faire vraiment un lien entre les
ministères ça concerne l'éducation ça
concerne l'enseignement supérieur ça
concerne l'intérieur ça défense les
armées bien sûr et ça concerne bien
au-delà du ministère de la Justice je
crois que c'est ce liant là qui manque à
mon sens sur le plan
institutionnel merci Madame douset
quelques mots quelques mots ou je vais
être extrêmement rapide sur les
conditions vous disiez levé ou àevé par
la loi pour l'impunité nous on va pas
parler de Doig mais au niveau du du CISR
nous invitons en fait tous les états les
196 États qui sont partis au Convention
de Genève de
2949 qui se sont engagés au terme de
l'article 1 à respecter et à faire
respecter le DIH en toutes circonstances
je dis toujours aux étudiants c'est une
obligation ce n'est pas une option et
donc deux moyens principaux d'abord la
prévention prévenir c'est dire que si on
prévient correctement par une par une
une législation justement interne qui
soit fidèle
alors on évitera que certains auteurs
complices commanditair échappent comme
vous le disiez à la loi donc prévenir
prévenir par une législation solide et
deuxièmement mise en œuvre fidèle je
disais et je reviens aux
condition que évoqué à l'instant par par
Aurélia et par vous-même et par et par
tous il n'y a pas que la double
incrimination qui pose problème selon
moi il y a vraiment la la la condition
de résidence habituelle euh la résidence
habituelle c'est pas la même chose que
la présence donc je pense que revenir à
la présence sur le sol français comme
c'est le cas pour d'autres infractions
internationales ce serait quand même le
minimum qu'on puisse faire pour des pour
des crimes internationaux que sont les
crimes de guerre les crimes contre
l'humanité et ensuite du coup j'en ai
perdu le fil c'est pas grave le la
l'autre vous vous con tout à l'heure oui
c'est le monopole du parquet je sais que
n'est pas d'accord mais le monopo je
tiens à le dire parce qu'il y a pas de
raison que une victime d'infraction
ordinaire ou d'agression ordinaire
puisse déclencher des poursuites et
passe la victime d'un crime de guerre ou
d'un crime contre l'humanité merci merci
Madame alors je passe la parole à
l'orateur du rassemblement national thba
François je vous remercie madame la
Présidente chers collègues mesdames mon
général je vous remercie pour votre
présence aujourd'hui dans un monde en
constante évolution où l'Occident doit
faire face à une réalité d'un monde
multipolarisé le droit international
humanitaire doit être notre référence
commune un point de départ pour un
échange et un respect entre les peuples
et les nations aussi la France doit
pouvoir porter sa voix non alignée
claire en veillant à ce que les
principes fondamentaux du droit
international de proportionnalité de
distinction de précaution restent des
remparts en préservant l'humanité de sa
propre destruction c'est dans ce même
esprit que nous portons au rassemblement
national la Déclaration des droits des
peuples et des nations celle-ci
s'articulant avec les instances
internationales évidemment et vis à
fixer un cadre qui soit plus juste de
relation entre les États respectant la
souveraineté des peuples et en
instaurant une équidistance entre toutes
les nations ces instances
internationales parfois critiqué
certains parfaites permettent néanmoins
d'échanger de parvenir à un consensus
comme au sein de l'ONU d'accepter des
gardes de fous et nous saluons ici le
travail du CICR et parfois même du
concours hélas nécessaire de la Cour de
justice internationale dans
l'établissement des responsabilité notre
famille politique tient à saluer
l'action du CICR qui en plus du rôle
humanitaire apporte sur le qu'il apporte
sur le terrain permet la diffusion et la
mise en œuvre du droit international
humanitaire les drames qui aujourd'hui
nous frappent particulièrement comme ce
en Ukraine et au Proche Orient ne
doivent ne pas nous faire oublier ce qui
se déroule dans d'autres pays notamment
au Nigéria au Congo en Éthiopie et je
souhaite aujourd'hui m'arrêter sur la
situation en arménnie le blocus du
hakaba organisé par l'Azerbaïjan qui
entrave tout acheminement d'aide
humanitaire aux populations vulnérables
a conduit finalement à l'annexion
définitif de ce territoire par
l'Azerbaïdjan or le droit international
en la matière est très clair les partis
doivent permettre de faciliter le
passage rapide et sans entrave de l'aide
humanitaire pour tous les civils qui en
ont besoin comme notre commission
devrait très proch prainement travailler
à une résolution concernant l'Arménie
pourriez-vous me donner votre analyse
sur les événements au ha Kabak et
peut-être nous informer de la situation
aujourd'hui et mon Général pourriez-vous
nous indiquer si vos services sont
impliqués sur place je vous
remercie merci chers collègues général
je vous laisse répondre et effectivement
à 12h30 nous accueillerons la présidente
du groupe d'amitié Arménie pour désigner
un rapporteur sur la responsable pardon
sur la PPR alors sur la description de
ce qui se passe dans l' haut carabar je
pense que Madame dousé sera la plus à
même de de de de de de vous répondre et
et pour ce qui concerne l'Office je vais
lui laisser beaucoup de temps puisque la
réponse est claire et simple c'est non
pas de dossier ouvert à
l'office je je vais être très très Brè
également parce que le CISR que vous
connaissez bien obéit à un certain
nombre de principes d'action qui lui
permettent d'intervenir justement sur le
terrain et d'être le plus efficace
possible pour protéger les les victimes
euh et donc je ne peux pas donner
d'informations précises sur les constats
que le CICR fait dans un certain nombre
de pays dans celui que vous citez ou
dans d'autres mais ce que je peux dire
c'est que néanmoins c'est que vous avez
raison sur le sur le sur les principes
j'allais dire l'acheminement de l'aide
humanitaire doit bien sûr se faire et je
peux vous dire aussi que pratiquement
toujours le CIC alors dans cette région
que dans cette région comme dans bien
d'autres conflits souvent effectivement
le CISR est le seul ou la le seul
organisme humanitaire à à rester présent
et s'il est le seul organisme
humanitaire à être présent c'est
précisément parce qu'il obéit à à un
certain nombre de principes d'action et
surtout à un mode opératoire qui est
celui de la confidentialité
confidentialité ne voulant pas dire
silence neutralité ne voulant pas dire
silence non plus c'est dire que lorsque
l'on constate des violations comme celle
que vous avez cité et bien d'autres
encore dans ce conflit comme dans
d'autres comme dans d'autres
Moyen-Orient et ailleurs nous nous
entretenons directement avec les
responsables jusqu'au plus haut niveau
de l'État ou jusqu'au plus haut niveau
du groupe armé non étatique lorsqu'il
s'agit de de conflits armés dans
l'internationaux et c'est seulement en
bilatéral que nous faisons part de de
nos de nos constats de nos réactions de
nos recommandations et nous revenons à
la charge aussi longtemps aussi souvent
que possible pour amener un meilleur
respect merci beaucoup madame douset
ensuite groupe suivant pour la France
insoumise nupes je passe la parole à
Nathalie osol pour 2 minutes 30 merci
madame la Présidente le 26 janvier
dernier soit il y a 5 jours la Cour
internationale de Justice organisation
directement liée à l'organisation des
Nations Unies rendait sa décision après
avoir été saisie par l'Afrique du Sud à
propos de la guerre menée par l'État
d'Israël à Gaza la démarche visait à
évaluer quelles mesures prendre par
qu'il existe un risque perçu de génocide
sans attendre un jugement définitif je
vais commencer par prendre quelques
précautions de définition et de
périmètre la notion de génocide est
complexe lourde de sens on comprend
qu'il faut peser de quoi on parle et
d'ailleurs on n' pas le même angle de
considération selon qu'on parle d'un
point de vue juridique ou politique et
donc la Cour internationale de justice
ne prend pas de décision politique mais
la boussole du politique doit être le
droit international et le respect des
termes et des décisions prises par par
l'ONU et ses instances donc la Cour
internationale de Justice jugeant droit
sur ce que les parties prenantes d'une
convention portant ici sur le génocide
peuvent faire pour prévenir et condamner
les éventuelles génocides ou situations
génocidaires pour se faire et respecte
une convention universelle et lorsqu'il
y a risque de génocide nous pouvons
prendre des mesures conservatoires nous
parlons de notre côté à la France
insoumiss de risqu génocidaires ou de
pentees génocidairees pris par le
gouvernement de netaniaahou en Israël et
d'ailleurs quatre des CIN critères qui
définissent un génocide ont été vérifiés
par la Cour internationale de justice la
situation à Gaza suscite notre émotion
et notre indignation sans aucun doute on
parle de quasiment 30000 morts on est
dans une situation de massacre de masse
que l'attaque du groupe armé du Hamas je
reprends les termes de la Cour
internationale de justice ne peuvent
nullement justifier et donc tenir ferme
sur les principes de droit international
c'est refusé par exemple l'affrontement
des religions et nous devons prendre en
consid fédération la décision de la Cour
internationale de justice qui vise à
enrayer la spirale infernale et
interminable de la violence des
obligations incombent à la France su
suite à cette décision et du fait de
notre adhésion à la Convention puisque
la France est signataire chaque
état-membre a le devoir de prendre des
mesures dans la prévention et la
condamnation de situations génocidaires
donc ce n'est pas une affaire juste
entre l'Afrique du Sud et Israël donc
comment la France peut-elle participer à
la désescalade à l' ence de cesser le
feu à Gaza au respect du droit
international par exemple l'Union
européenne a l'habitude dans ces cas-là
d'accentuer l' d'humanitaire de prendre
des sanctions économiques de rompre des
relations diplomatiques d'arrêter la
livraison d'armes et je je termine d'un
mot dans le passé l'Office central de
lutte contre les crimes contre
l'humanité et les crimes de haine et le
pôle crime contre l'humanité du tribunal
judiciaire de Paris se sont chargé de
mener des enquêtes est-ce que des
procédures similaires sont sont
envisagées dans la situation de de
guerre à Gaza est-ce que des
investigations sont en cours sur les
crimes de guerre commis par le Hamas
contre des ressortissants français et
contre des ressortissants français
faisant partie de l'É pardon mais voilà
la faute est à la présidente qui a voulu
laisser terminer une phrase mais qui
était avec beaucoup de
circonvolution c'est c'est noté alors
merci pour vot merci pour votre question
nous entrons dans le dur dans un sujet
qui est chargé de d'émotions mais nous
allons l'aborder en droit sous l'angle
froid et despassionné du droit peut-être
madame
Devos pour 2 minutes 30 je vais tâcher
d'être extrêmement respectueuse du
temps merci je vous remercie alors
simplement quand même pour préciser la
Cour internationale de justice ce n'est
pas une c'est pas une juridiction pénale
donc ça je pense que c'est important de
le dire dire la Cour internationale de
justice elle se penche sur la question
de savoir s'il y a ou pas une violation
par l'état des obligation qui sont mus
par la Convention génocide de pour la
prévention et la répression du génocide
de
1948 c'est important de le dire le
génocide n'est jamais commis par un état
le génocide c'est'est commis par des
individus donc il y a là une nuance
qu'il faut quand même avoir quand même à
l'esprit la Cour internationale de
justice ne pourra pas dire ne peut pas
dire ne dit pas et ne pourra pas dire il
y a un génocide ou il peut y avoir un
génocide c'est pas son rôle hein c'est
vraiment un rôle par rapport à la
Convention je crois que ça c'est
important quand même de le dire j'attire
quand même l'attention de la part de la
juriste que je suis avec ma vision pénal
sur l'importance des mots et
l'importance des qualifications dans le
génocide qui à mon sens c'est quand même
une qualification rarissime et je pense
que c'est important de le dire
l'intention alité de l'auteur est au
cœur du sujet la quantité de victimes la
l'horreur de ce qui se produit n'est pas
un critère de définition d'un acte de
génocide le cœur du sujet c'est
l'intention c'est sononder l'intention
des individus qui agissent et ce qu'il y
a à l'intérieur de leur cœur et de leur
âme pour savoir ont-ils la volonté de
détruire un groupe national un groupe
ethnique pour ce qu' l' profondément
c'est ça le génocide et je pense que je
pourrais simplement ajouter un point euh
le crime de guerre ça n'est pas pas
grave je pense que c'est quand même un
peu important de le dire le crime de
guerre ça n'est pas pas grave si ce sont
des crimes de guerre c'est déjà très
grave si ce sont des crimes contre
l'humanité c'est déjà très grave et que
euh il n'y a pas de hiérarchie euh à
faire entre les victimes de crimes de
guerre ou de crimes de génocide je pense
que ça c'est important et je pense que
c'est aussi le rôle des juristes de
rappeler ce genre de choses il y a en
France je parle sous votre contrôle
général des enquêtes qui concernent
effectivement des Français victimes du
Hamas pour les action du 7 octobre à mon
sens sauf si je me trompe uniquement sur
la qualification de crime à caractère
terroriste il y a peut-être une
réflexion qui est menée sur la
qualification de crime contre l'humanité
pour le 7 octobre par par qu'il y a des
plaintes qui ont été médiatisées qui ont
été déposées par des familles de
victimes je pense que ça doit être à
l'analyse et je m'arrêterai là voilà
merci pour votre éclairage pour le
groupe les républicains je vais passer
la parole à meilleur Habib théoriquement
pour 2 minutes 30 et j'ai bien noté que
mais je plafon à 2 minutes 58 vous avez
la parole chers
collègues micro tu un micro est allumé
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
générales samedi nous commémorions le
79e anniversaire de la libération du
candchwitz journée internationale de la
choie en souvenir des 6 millions de
juifs déportés massacrés gazés brûlés
dans le silence coupable des nations
mais aussi de la Croix-Rouge ce qui fut
unique entre 40 et 45 ce F ce fut
délaissement écrivait les vinaces à la
découverte plus grand crime de
l'humanité de l'histoire nevera gain fut
le mot d'or du monde libre et auguré la
création de notre système juridique
international qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui pourtant le 7 octobre 2023
des djihadistes Palestiniens du Hamas
récidivé en une journée en tuant 1200
civiles massacrés femmes violées des
femmes violées souillées des familles
entières décimées brûlé vives des
enfants décapités des corps mutulés des
centaines de d'entre eux dont des
Français pris en otage euh dont des
rescapés de 45 en fait une choix en un
jour à la différence des nazis qui
cachaient leur crimes les djihadistes
eux les brandissent comme des trophées
dans une aatation du mal la guerre a été
imposé à Israël ce n'est pas une
vengeance c'est une justice la justice
face au plus grand porô de l'histoire
dont certains nî existence comme les
négationnistes d'hier Israël aujourd'hui
doit faire face à ceux qui renversent
comme ici la charge de de l'accusation
le bourreau devient la victime comme un
munique en 38 les puissances
international se drape dans les nzonir
on refuse de voir que le djihadisme qui
a défiguré notre pays en France et la
France et le nazisme d'hier 80 ans après
la Choa la morale internationale des
raill à la haie des régimes corrompu et
criminogène donne des leçons à la seule
démocratie du Moyen-Orient pendant ce
simulacre de procès on apprend que
l'unra agence de l'ONU a participé
activement au massacre du 7 octobre on
accuse Israël de génocide contre une
population et qui a qu'int tuplé en 50
ans alors que après la Choa le peuple
juif en Europe est passé de 9 millions à
3 millions silence pour la des millions
de morts en Syrie en Afghanistan au
Darfour au Yémen silence sur les
famillesid la la répression en Iran
depuis 2015 l'ONU a voté 140 résolutions
condamnatoire contre Israël prise la
moitié pourquoi cette obsession des
Nations Unies contre le seul et
minuscule État juif qui doit lutter pour
vivre aujourd'hui face sur se front pour
survivre encore quel pourquoi la
Croix-Rouge je refuseelle de rendre
visite aux otages détenus dont les
familles sont sans nouvelles depuis 115
jours pourquoi j'accuse ce système
international d'être obsédé par Israël
et de la haine du Juif pourquoi la
justice internationale aujourd'hui est
infiltrée manipulée par les mêmes
antisémites qui siègent parfois aussi
sur les hélas sur le siège de notre
assemblée pourquoi les S gardent ce
silence passent au crime de l'humanité
madame merci je crois que la la Croix
Rouge est interpellé donc je vais vous
proposer de répondre madame
douset
h non je ne vais pas je ne vais pas
répondre ce que je voudrais dire c'est
que le CICR justement parce qu'il est
neutre indépendant et impartial c'est en
cela qu'il est le le mandataire j'allais
dire
des on va laisser la parole à on va
laisser la parole à l'intervenante par
respect par respect pour nos
intervenants je propose qu'après chaque
question on laisse la parole à
l'intervenante CISR N et le DIH
d'ailleurs n'a pour seul parti que celui
des victimes quel qu'elle soit où
qu'elle soit et comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure nous discutons et nous
dialoguons avec tout le monde à la fois
avec les états avec les groupes armés
non étatiques mais nous ne forçons pas
la porte n ne faisons pas d'ingérence
qu'elle soit humanitaire par exemple
auprès de n'importe qui je pourrais en
discuter avec vous si vous le souhaitez
mais à un autre moment mais il faut pas
se il faut pas se lancer dans ce type de
polémique qui qui ne fait pas avancer
les choses le CICR n'est rien à lui seul
il n'est que ce que veulent bien en
faire les États et les groupes armés non
étatiques encore une fois avec lesquels
nous dialoguons et qui dans bien
d'autres cas mais aussi peut-être dans
celui-ci permettent de de faire avancer
de faire avancer les choses il y a eu
récemment d'ailleurs un accord pour nous
permettre de fournir des médicaments aux
otages qui sont détenus par le Hamas ce
n'est qu'un exemple mais je ne veux pas
aller plus loin dans dans cette
démonstration c'est juste je ne crois
pas que je fasse bien mais je pense que
c'est préférable pour tous juste madame
douset pour que je comprenne bien et
sans vouloir relancer euh le CICR n'a
pas accès aux otages israéliens et et
d'autres nationalités détenu par le
Hamas c'est ça non et ce n'est pas faute
de négocier et de dialoguer et de
demander euh au Hamas euh d'avoir accès
euh la seule chose que je puis encore
vous dire c'est que nous avons donc
comme vous l'avez rappelé facilité la
libération puis ensuite le transfert
d'un certain nombre d'otages 150 et
quelques en j'ai plus le nombre
exact et récemment là de faciliter aussi
l'envoi encore une fois de de
médicaments mais vraiment de manière
générale et sans vouloir se focaliser
sur sur ce conflit- là de manière
générale tant que les États les partis
au conflit qu'ell soit étatique ou non
étatique n'auront pas compris qu'il faut
effectivement laisser la place à des
organismes humanitaires neutres
indépendants et impartiaux comme le CICR
pour
intervenir un un un médecin ancien
délégué il est mort maintenant le
premier à être rentré à Hiroshima écrit
un bouquin qui s'appelle le troisème
combattant c'est ce que je j'aime bien
j'aime bien cette appellation le
troisème combattant pour désigner ce que
fait le ce que fait le CISR mais le CISR
ne peut pas forcer les portes ça je
crois qu'il faut bien le comprendre que
les États s'unissent et fassent tout ce
qui est en leur possible
et pour qu'il facilite si vous voulez
l'acheminement des des secours
humanitaires je reviens juste à un
moment on a parlé beaucoup de terrorisme
juste un mot si vous le permettez il
faut cesser aussi de prendre les
humanitaires c'est pas trop le cas du
CISR mais ça peut être le cas d'autres
il faut cesser de prendre les
humanitaires pour des délinquants qui ne
feraient qu'aider les terroristes entre
guillemets de n'importe quel groupe armé
nonétatiqu les humanitaires ne sont pas
des délinquants ce sont des personnes
qui interviennent au service et pour
pour protéger les personnes confrontées
à un conflit armé merci Madame douset le
message est bien reçu pour le groupe
démocrate et indépendant Laurence
vichnievski vous avez la parole pour 2
minutes
30 merci madame la Présidente et merci
aux intervenants pour leur éclairage
alors moi qui est un assez long passé de
magistrat je me disais que toutes les
notions qui ont été
évoquées ne doivent pas être évidentes à
percevoir immédiatement parce qu'elles
sont complexes et que je reconnais euh
parfois me perdre aussi je n'évoquerai
pas la Cour de justice internationale
parce que vous l'avez dit Madame ce
n'est pas une cour pénale et nous sommes
nous traitons aujourd'hui de crimes qui
sont de la compétence de juridiction
pénale et vous-même étiz à la tête d'un
parquet pénal et je préfère revenir à
des des notions un peu juridique après
les deux échanges précédents alors je
crois que au plan euh si ce bilan est
est est à la fois
positif la création de votre pôle était
est est antérieur de très peu à mon
départ de la magistrature donc je me dis
que des progrès ont été faits la
création de cet office central aussi
donc il y a au moins cette prise de
conscience et même si les moyens sont
sont sont insuffisants euh j'ai connu
une période où la compétence universelle
par exemple c'était une notion qui
n'avait absolument pas cours alors
malgré ces progrès le bilan en général
de la de la justice pénale
internationale est assez mitigé mais
pour des raisons je dirais déjà
politiques structurellement des états
comme la Russie les États-Unis la Chine
n'ont pas ratifier euh le Statut de Rome
donc évidemment euh la porté est plus
limité de cette juridiction de la Cour
pénale
internationale par ailleurs il y a aussi
un rapport force un rapport de force au
sein du Conseil de sécurité qui parfois
empêche le déferrement
euh de d'agissement répréhensible devant
la CPI et je pense à Pékin et Moscou
hein qui avait bloqué en 2014 un projet
de résolution qui tendz à déférer des
crimes commis en Syrie alors euh je vais
très vite sur ma conclusion encore que
je pourrais prétendre à 3 minutes
peut-être aussi mais s'agissant de de la
question que je voudrais poser je
voudrais vous poser
elle a trait à cette compétence
universelle dont on a parlé et qui est
euh un concept nouveau est-ce que vous
pensez euh malgré les difficultés de
preuve et peut-être vous vous
développerez aussi là-dessus et des
difficultés qui tiennent aussi à la
protection des droits de la défense
est-ce que çaa peut
être une réponse complémentaire à
l'intervention de la cour pénal
internationale elle-même limitée par des
considérations politiques merci alors
qui veut qui veut répondre madame devous
oui merci pour votre question alors
cette compétence universelle elle peut
être complémentaire je dirait même plus
qu'elle doit être
complémentaire elle a le devoir d'être
complémentaire par parce que alors si
les tribunaux ad hoc avaient une
primauté ça n'empêchait pas sur les
états ça n'empêchait pas qu'on puisse
avoir des dossiers aujourd'hui la cor
pénale internationale il y a un complexe
il y a un concept de complémentarité
alors cette complémentarité c'est avec
les états sur les territoires desquels
les crimes ont été commis donc la
justice doit aussi agir la Cour l'a
beaucoup impulsé en Guinée en Colombie
hein on sait que les États se sont
saisis finalement de la poursuite de ces
crimes sur les lieux et puis il y a tous
ces états qui applique la compétence
universelle bien sûr que ça doit être
complémentaire on comprend très bien que
la Cour pénale internationale ne peut
viser que les plus haut responsable et
que c'est très limité ce sont quelques
personnes en 20 ans qui ont pu être
traduits devant la Cour et répondre de
de leurs actes face à l'ampleur des
crimes à l'ampleur du nombre des
exécutants et des décideur de ces crimes
on comprend très bien que la justice
internationale ne peut pas être
simplement portée par les juridictions
internationales donc c'est en effet
complémentaire et ça l'est parce que
nous sommes tous concernés par une sorte
de mondialisation des trajets des
échanges des mouvements et que quand des
événements comme en Syrie se produisent
nous avons sur notre territoire dans les
années qui suivent de nombreuses
victimes qui ont fu de nombreux témoins
d'exaction et de nombreux auteurs de
crime qui au gré des mouvements entre
2012 et 2022 2023 on pensait qu'à
certains moment ils allaient être en
disgrâce et à un moment donné quittent
le territoire et viennent se réfugier en
France en Suède en Allemagne en Belgique
aux États-Unis et bien évidemment il est
pas il est pas possible ni tolérable
quand il n'y a pas de possibilité
d'extradition vers un autre pays ou vers
la juridiction internationale de remise
que on puisse être un refuge pour ça
c'est c'est ça le sens de la compétence
universelle en fait c'est un filet à
poisson qui doit être le plus avec des
mailles plus serré possible pour qu'on
puisse pas être totalement dans
l'impunité où que ce soit c'est c'est ça
le sens de la compétence universelle
c'est pas le sens d'aller se mêler des
affaires des autres ni de poser des
problèmes diplomatiques c'est pas ça qui
qui recherché merci de de cette
précision effectivement qui montre notre
responsabilité pour les socialistes et
apparentés je passe la parole à Alain
David merci merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames général chers collègues merci
de vos exposés liumminires qui sont
édifiants et et qui alimenteront les les
travaux de notre commission pour de
nombreux mois au vu de la terrible
actualité internationale que ce soit en
Ukraine Proche-Orient au Congo entre
autres cela a été souligné à plusieurs
reprises les crimes de guerre les
génocid les crimes contre l'humanité
sont souvent caractérisés par leur
éloignement géographique ou dans le
temps j'ajouterai ainsi deux exemples
aux nombreux qui ont été cités celui des
Ouigours en Chine et celui de la jeunte
birmane contre ses propres populations
en
Birmanie notre assemblée avait en
janvier
2022 adopté à la quasi unanimité une
résolution condamnant le caractère
génocidaire des violences politiques
systématiques ainsi que des crimes
contre l'humanité perpétrés par la Chine
à l'égard des
Ouigours notre action de législateur
faisait ainsi modestement écho aux
travaux des ONG des enquêteurs ou de la
justice dans le cas de la Birmanie la
jeunte multiplie les exactions depuis le
coup d'État du 1er février 2021 de
nombreuses ONG documentent ces crimes
mais ils se produisent trop souvent loin
de la tension
médiatique de fait il est toujours
délicat de sensibiliser l'opinion
publique sur ceci ma question sera donc
simple sans nous dévoiler d'éventuelles
informations sensibles est-il
envisageable que les crimes contre les
Ouigours
ou contre les populations birmanes
puissent un jour faire l'objet de
procédures plus concrètes que les
condamnations symboliques dont elles
font aujourd'hui l'objet t elles font
aujourd'hui l'objet j'ai j'ai cru
déceler madame la procureure une
certaine solitude des magistrats
affectés à ce poste en est-il ainsi dans
les autres pays existe-t-il par contre
des pays plus enthousiastes
dirons-nous pour travailler le sujet et
en particulier au niveau des moyens
merci merci chers collègues et merci de
de rappeler à notre mémoire
effectivement les événements affectant
les Ouigours et les birms je passé la
parole au général pour essayer
d'équilibrer les temps de parole merci
je vais je vais essayer de d'être
relativement clair sur sur le sujet
euh les critères de compéten et
juridiction françaises ont été rappelés
par Madame Devos dans son propos
préliminaire et et ils sont au nombre de
trois enfin si on parle si on parle de
la compétence universelle à ma
connaissance il n'y a pas de franco
chinois concernés par des actes que vous
dénoncez en Chine victime des des
agissements donc pas de compétenence
possible de ce point de vue-là de la
même chose en terme de compétenence
personnelle active pas d'auteur présumé
franco-chinois ou français présents sur
le territoire chinois à qui on pourrait
reprocher ses faits donc pas de
compétenence possible dans ce domaine là
reste donc le la possibilité d'être
saisi au titre de la compétence quasi
universelle mais là on se heurte à enfin
on se heurte ce on reste dans les
critères fixés par la loi de la
présence la résidence habituelle en
France d'un auteur
présumé se pose donc cette cette cette
barrière cette limite
alors des organisations non
gouvernementales euh plaignantes ont
cherché en France mais aussi dans
d'autres pays européens à faire ouvrir
des enquêtes judiciaires et c'est ce
qu'on évoquait précédemment au titre de
la complicité notamment des entreprises
de textile qui auraient eu
à industrialiser leurs produits à partir
de coton chinois produit dans cette
région par des populations Ouigour qui
qui seraient placé euh qui serait
esclavagisé euh C ces procédures n'ont
pas n'ont pas perduré n'ont pas n'ont
pas pu avoir de suite
Judit merci je crois que Madame Devos
vous voulez ajouter un mot oui
simplement vous remercier de ce mot sur
la solitude parce que en effet vous avez
bien perçu les procureurs et enquêteurs
et et magistrats qui s'occupe de ces
sujets sont effectivement relativement
seuls il l'était un petit peu plus il y
a 15 ans dans une institution judiciaire
qui était pas du tout mobilisée par le
sujet ils le sont un petit peu moins
mais ça demeure et c'est aussi le cas
parfois dans d'autres États et ce réseau
génocide qui nous regroupe tous nous
fait percevoir que dans chacun des États
concernés finalement c'est pas forcément
la première des priorités pas toujours
parce que bien évidemment euh chacun se
concentre sur ses affaires dites plus
intérieures et plus immédiates donc bien
sûr un peu de solitude
évidemment merci je vais passer la
parole pour horizon et apparenté à la
députée Stéphanie cochert merci madame
la Présidente Mesdames général je
souhaitais à mon tour revenir sur la
situation au au Kabak on voit dans ce
conflit et par le nettoyage ethnique de
l'Azerbaïjan que subissent les
populations arméniennes qu'il est
malheureusement plus simple de constater
des crimes que de les punir en effet
fuyant les bombes et l'avancée des
troupes azerbaïjan naise plus de 100000
Arméniens du haut carabach ont ainsi fui
en quelques jours vers la République
d'Arménie voisine le nettoyage ethnique
en cours amorcé pendant la guerre de
2020 est le résultat d'une stratégie
délibérée visant à éliminer la présence
arménienne au Kabak situation dénoncée
par une proposition de résolution
européenne dont parlait madame la
Présidente que notre Commission
examinera en février cette stratégie se
manifeste non seulement par le
déplacement forcé des populations mais
également par la détérioration à la
destruction du patrimoine culturel et
religieux religieux pardon arménien dans
les régions désormais sous le contrôle
de l'Azerbaïdjan l'Union européenne a
déployé une mission pour contribuer à la
stabilité de la frontière avec l'Arménie
et la Cour internationale de justice a
ordonné à l'Azerbaïdjan de permettre un
retour sur des habitants du
haut-karabach à ce stade et selon vos
expertise quelles autres mesures peuvent
mettre en œuvre les nations l'Union
européenne et les organ tion
internationale pour obliger
l'Azerbaïdjan à respecter le droit
international merci qui veut répondre à
cette question épineuse madame de vos
alors je je me lance pour répondre à
cette question épineuse alors ce que je
dois dire d'abord c'est que il y a deux
temps dans la réaction à mon avis à
avoir c'est le temps de l'urgence c'est
le recueil des informations des preuves
donc des informations qui qui peuvent
devenir des preuves donc les témoignages
les constatations tout ce qui peut
préserver ce qui va nourrir
effectivement l'information sur
l'intention des auteurs pour quelles
raisons les buts les objectifs des
documentation des propos publques
éventuellement donc des des actions donc
tout ce qui peut être préservé et qui
potentiellement dans le temps peut
disparaître parce que c'est c'est bien
ça la difficulté c'est-à-dire que le
général en parlait tout à l'heure le
temps fait disparaître les preuves en
fait à parfois apparaître d'autres
permet du recul mais nous fait perdre un
certain nombre d'éléments et donc la
première des chose c'est que tout ce qui
peut être mis en place pour ce recueil
ce collecte de preuves et leur
extraction comme ça a pu être fait pour
l'Ukraine au sein d'eurjust par exemple
leur extraction dans des lieux sécurisés
c'est une bonne chose et c'est la
première chose à laquelle il faut penser
vient ensuite le temps de l'analyse et
de la qualification juridique
éventuellement de ce qui est en train de
se produire
et ça ça prend évidemment un peu plus de
temps donc en réalité c'est les choses
qui peuvent être mises en place c'est
surtout une réaction à l'urgence pour
peut-être approcher des personnes qui
ont été victimes qui ont été témoins
recueillir le maximum de choses donc des
au sein de l'Union européenne il y a
peut-être des choses à faire au sein des
Nations Unies aussi pour essayer de
figer un certain nom d'éléments c'est la
réponse que je peux je peux à ce stade
vous apporter qui me semble la plus
pertinente
merci nous reparlerons sans doute l
après cette séance quand nous
accueillerons Anne Laurence PEL et que
nous procéderons à la désignation du
responsable de texte sur la résolution
européenne nous reviendrons j'auraai des
d'autres éléments à vous donner sur la
situation au carabach je vais passer la
parole pour la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine à Jean-Paul Lecoq notre
vice-président merci madame la
Présidente j'aurais trop de choses à
vous dire je peux pas le dire mais mais
je vais faire un peu à la prêverre
premier aspect c'est que d'abord la
Croix-Rouge j'aimerais lui dire je vous
attends avec impatience dans les
territoires occupés du Sahara Occidental
puisque on espère qu'un jouur la
Croix-Rouge s'intéresse à ce sujetlà
euh je voudrais dire sur les questions
de des organisations internationales de
de solidarité euh moi l'agence de l'ONU
qui a eu en son sein 10 15 peut-être 20
criminels qui se sont associés au 7
octobre je je pense qu'elle a déjà réagi
et je pense que ces criminels doivent
être jugés et punis justice doit être
rendue aux victimes du 7 octobre mais
c'est pas toute l'agence euh ça veut
dire que les milliers de personnes qui
travaillent dans cette agence là on peut
pas les considérer comme des criminels
les 160 qui ont été tués assassinés dans
la bande de Gaza on peut pas les
considérer tous comme des criminels et
donc il faut être prudent sur la façon
dont on juge madame dev vos vous avez
parlé des des verrous de de ces
verrouses qui protège quelque part
parfois les auteurs de crimes de guerre
lorsqu'ils viennent dans notre pays
lorsqu'ils traversent notre pays et
qu'on peut pas forcément vous avez
parler de maille du filet j'ai
l'impression que ces verrous ont donné à
la France des grandes mailles du filet
qui fait que les ce type de poissons
peuvent passer au travers et et vous
êtes dans la commission qui a voté je
crois à l'unanimité de mémoire le fait
que ces verrous n'étaient pas bons et
qu'il fallait ne pas les mettre et que
c'était la commission des lois puis le
Sénat qui ont eux considérer que ces
verrous devaient être respectés donc
nous ici enfin en tout cas moi j'y étais
à l'époque on est on est complètement
d'accord avec vous et on pense que il
aurait fallu que la France soit plus
dure dans son droit pour justement
pouvoir arrêter les les les auteurs de
crimes de guerre ou de crime contre
l'humanité moi j'avais dit à un premier
ministre israélien après l'opération
plomburci que j'espérais que le jour où
il mettra les pieds dans mon pays il
soit arrêté pour être jugé pour les
crimes de guerre à l'occasion de cette
opération plond je dirai la même chose
aujourd'hui à Benjamin natanahou si je
le voyais pour lui dire vous devrez
aussi si vous mettez les pieds et je
dirai la même chose au aux criminels et
à ceux qui ont commandité les crimes du
7 octobre mais les mais les les on
laisse parler le l'orateur il vous reste
quelques dizaines de secondes ah non
puisqu'on a pas de dynamique pour
pouvoir parler donc je vais je vais
laisser comme ça je pense que la les
républicains sont les maîtres de cette
commission et c'est pas vous madame la
Présidente et c'est vraiment dommage
donc vous avez dit un certain nombre de
choses sur le Sahara Occidental sur
l'uneeri sur la levée des verrous et sur
vos expressions fortes sur des
responsables israéliens donc je pense
que votre parole a été entendue je vais
demander à nos intervenants de répondre
l'exercice est difficile hein mais qui
veut répondre peut-être sur le Sahara
occidental pour
commencer non
euh sur les autres
thèmes alors j'y
vais euh alors il les verrous
euh j'aime pas tellement cette
expression euh c'est pas une expression
de juriste je dirais c'est plutôt euh
donc je vous la laisse moi je dirais des
conditions hein bon c'est peut-être
moins euh moins moins polémique alors
les conditions effectivement hein sur
euh les crimes contre l'humanité crimes
de guerre quand on a adapté le Statut de
Rome monopole des poursuites par le
parquet euh la résidence habituelle et
puis cette double incrimination qui euh
qu'on dont on a déjà parlé alors euh sur
le monopole des poursuites par le
parquet je sais que euh effectivement ça
peut être
discuté moi je suis magistrat j'applique
ce que dit aussi le législateur voyez ça
m'empêche pas d'avoir une opinion de
l'expérience euh qui est la mienne je
dis aussi attention euh à une possible
instrumentalisation dans ces domaines-là
avec des plaintes à Touva qui sont
déposés justement parce qu'on met les
pieds sur le territoire français on a dû
se garder dans certaines circonstances
de de ce genre de de d'attitude c'est
vrai aussi il faut aussi le dire ça
n'est pas sont pas des conditions qui
simplement vont venir empêcher de
poursuivre un certain nombre de
personnes parfois c'est aussi faire le
tri en dans un certain nombre de
situations au-delà de ça ça veut pas
dire que la les victimes ou les ONG
peuvent pas saisir la justice parce que
déposer des plainte auprès d'un
procureur de la République c'est quand
même pas rien il faut qu'on justifie
quand on classe ou quand on fait en on
peut contester ces classements devant le
procureur général donc c'est vrai que
c'est pas des constitutions de partie
civile devant des juges d'instruction
mais ça n'est pas non plus une absence
d'accès à la justice alors après
effectivement ça c'est un choix
politique du législateur sur la question
de la résidence habituelle simplement
une une remarque sur la différence entre
présence et résidence effectivement
première remarque c'est que sur le plan
opérationnel c'est extrêmement compliqué
pour les magistrats et les enquêteurs d'
avoir deux régimes différents ça veut
dire qu'il faut savoir immédiatement
s'il s'agit de torture au sens de la
Convention de 84 ou de torture qui
seraient constitutive de CRIM contre
l'humanité et là on n pas la même régime
on n' pas les mêmes conditions or au
début d'une enquête on comprend très
bien quand même qu'on a du mal à savoir
parfois comment qualifier les choses
donc là complexification du travail des
enquêteurs et des magistrats deuxième
remarque très rapidement c'est
que sur le fondement de la presse
aucune arrestation ou aucune action
judiciaire n'aura lieu si quelqu'un
vient sur le territoire français pendant
2 jours qui accepterait qu'on place en
garde à vue une personne sur le
fondement d'allégation dans la presse ou
même d'une plainte qui est déposée avec
des témoignages qui n'ont pas été pris
d'enquête qui n'a pas été faite en
réalité c'est un critère qui n'a pu
trouver à s'appliquer que de manière
extrêmement résiduelle quand des
enquêtes avaient déjà eu lieu était déjà
en cours et que les personnes font des
allés-retours comme dans le cas de
Lumbala en RDC qui a pu être réarrêté
voilà merci pour ces précisions très
importantes dernière orateur au titre
des non inscrits Madame Véronique B vous
avez 2 minutes 30 merci beaucoup merci à
à vous trois pour votre présence ce
matin et vosos interventions très
intéressantes des sujets graves
évidemment qu'il qu'il faut aborder
impérativement vu le contexte
international et les situations propris
à de T crime semble se multiplier et
votre travail d'enquête et de mise en
lumière des des actes commis et est
vraiment très important j'avais deux
questions mais en fait il y en a une à
laquelle vous avez répondu concerne
l'Arménie donc j'en ai plus qu'une il
s'agit euh je vrais aborder la la
question des chrétiens dans le monde la
première concerne donc l'index de
persécution des chrétiens 2023 publié
cour en janvier par l'ONG portes
ouvertes on y apprend que les violences
commises dans le le monde contre les
chrétiens ont augmenté de 22 % en 10 ans
un chrétien sur est fortement persécuté
et discriminé en raison de sa foi soit
360 millions de personnes à travers le
monde il y a un nombre record d'églises
ciblé he on en pas parle de de 10000
églises par exemple en Chine et environ
13 chrétiens sont tués en moyenne par
jour 78 pays sont pointés du doigt pour
ces actes de persécution et certains
détiennent de tristes records 4125
chrétiens sont détenus dans le monde don
la moitié en Inde 3300 chrétiens ont été
kidnappés au Nigéria d'ailleurs le
Nigéria comptabilise à lui seul 82 % des
chrétiens tué en raison de leur foi soit
plus de 4000 personnes dernier grand
drame en date massacre de 200 chrétiens
au moment de Noël dernier meurtre
emprisonnement persécution pour des
motifs d'ordre religieux disparition
forcée beaucoup de caractéristiques de
crime contre l'humanité dans ces actes
d'autant plus que ces crimes sont bien
souvent commis en temps de paix tant et
si bien qu'on puisse parler de de de
paix évidemment dans le cadre de ces
crimes alors quelle est dès lors la la
la polition de la justice internationale
et du CRC CIRC sur ces crimes ciblés
contre une population en raison de sa
foi et général l'Office travaille-t-elle
travaille-t-il pardon sur ce sujet et
des mesures sont-elles prises concernant
tout particulièrement le Nigéria où les
actes antichrétiens sont beaucoup plus
nombreux merci madame monsieur ah pardon
général vousz les répondre allez-y alors
non on n'a pas de dossier ouvert
concernant des attaques de chrétiens au
Nigéria simplement pour les raisons que
j'aiévoqué précédemment relative au au
igour c'estàdire que les les critères de
compétence juridiction française ne sont
pas nécessairement remplis euh c'est ce
qui fait c'est ce qui fait la
différence l'aspect enfin religieux des
victimes est peut-être un critère qui
justifie les persécutions entre
guillemets les dont ils font dont ils
font l'objet dans le dans le pays dont
ils sont originaires et ça peut
évidemment entraîner une qualification
pénale des faits particulière en
fonction des des des preuves qui qui
sont
recueillies mais à ce à ce stade il n'y
a pas d'enquête ouverte en France
concernant des des faits relatifs à des
persécutions de de religieux et de
chrétiens en
particulier alors madame Devos peut-être
vous pouvez ajouter on va
laisser on va laisser les personnes à
qui je donne le micro s'exprimer je vous
demande le respect des orateurs madame
Devos simplement pour vous indiquer que
on a eu l'occasion malheureusement de
travailler sur les chrétiens d'Orient
notamment les crimes commis en en Irak
par le groupe à caractère terroriste
daesch he par l'État islamique notamment
sur le terrain du crime contre
l'humanité preuve plus difficilement
accessible d'ailleurs que s'agissant des
yeszidi où on a pu avec un travail
extrêmement approfondi avec l'ocrvp avec
l'asdat avec la DGSI donc des services
qui liai à la fois l'antiterrorisme et
et je dirais le le droit commun pouvoir
travailler sur les crimes commis à
l'encontre des yésidis qu'on a qualifié
de génocide et pouvoir viser des
ressortissants français qui ont rejoint
les troupes de daesh euh pour et pour
ses faits en question sur les chrétiens
d'Orient ça a été plus compliqué parce
que effectivement la remontée de la
preuve a été plus moins évidente moins
facile à localiser car plus diffuse et
donc le la la manière de relier ces
faits à des ressortissants français qui
donc pourrai entraîner notre compétence
a été et sur le plan de l'enquête encore
plus compliqué donc là on seurte
effectivement un critère de compétence
mais c'est pas quelque chose qui euh a
été en dehors des radars qui est en
dehors des radars du du P crime contre
l'humanité merci alors il est 12h13 nous
avons encore un peu plus d'un quart
d'heure et j'ai SEP orateurs inscrits à
titre individuel cette fois-ci chacun
pose une question brève en une minute et
nos intervenants répondent en une minute
le premier orateur individuel sera donc
Didier parquan oui merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames Messieurs les
experts pardonnez-moi parce que le sujet
que je vais aborder a déjà été abordé ça
va être un peu redondant pardonnez mes
chers collègues parce que ce sujet me
tient vraiment à cœur aujourd'hui le
hautkarabach est vidé de ces 120000 âmes
depuis l'attaque ignoble de cette région
historiquement arménienne par
l'Azerbaïdjan en septembre dernier on
assiste sous nos yeux et impuissant une
véritable épuration ethnique ce n'est
pas moi qui le dis c'est ASM tolmadan
qui est l'ambassadrice d'Arménie en
France l'épuration ethnique c'est le
fait d'effacer la présence des Arméniens
dans ce territoire et c'est ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui plus un Arménien ne
vit dans le haut cararabak cependant en
droit international le terme de
nettoyage ethnique n'est pas reconnu
comme un crime et n'est pas de
définition précise selon l'ONU pour ma
part et comme le dit Luis Moreno Ocampo
ancien procureur de la Cour pénale
internationale je pense qu'on assiste à
un génocide puisque nous observons des
actes avérés avec l'intention de
détruire un groupe national ethnique
racial ou religieux parmi ces actes
figurent le blocus merci conclure la
famine l'exode on peut le voir il y a un
réel flou sur la qualification juridique
vous qui êtes des experts du droit
international quel est votre
positionnement sur la qualification
juridique de ce qui se passe à nartsar
merci
merci alors qui veut répondre nettoyage
ethnique ça n'est pas une qualification
juridique que
retenir moi j'ai je vais juste répéter
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
effectivement moi de mon positionnement
en tant que magistrat je vais pas me me
positionner sur une qualification
juridique sans avoir vu un un dossier
des éléments et cetera donc évidemment
je pense que ce n'est pas incongru de
penser à ses qualifications et en tout
cas il faut y réfléchir hein c'est pas
quelque chose de fantaisiste ce que vous
dites clairement mais par contre
effectivement je vais pas me positionner
c'est peut-être pas satisfaisant mais en
tout cas le magistrat peut pas se
positionner comme ça et je pense que
c'est même démocratique que ça soit le
cas
merci euh 2è orateur individuel Carlos
Marens
bilongo je remercie l'ensemble des
experts ici présents pour pour leur
précision je vais avoir une question
concernant l'Office central de lutte
contre les crimes contre l'humanité et
les crimes de la haine
euh le par le passé il y a eu des
procédures qui ont été ouvertes par le
tribunal de Paris concernant les crimes
de de guerre concernant Conant la guerre
en Ukraine j'aimerais savoir est-ce que
des procédures du même type sont
également menées concernant la situation
en Israël et en Palestine et est-ce
qu'il y a des investigations qui sont en
cours des ressortissants français
franco-israéliens qui sont engagés dans
l'armée salale et qui ont commis des
crimes de guerre après la décision de la
CJ je pense qu'il y a des précisions à
mener des investigations aussi à voir
concernant des ressortissants français
qui sert de retour sur notre territoire
après euh toutes ces situation sur les
populations de Gaza qui onuront subi qui
ont subi des exactions excusez-moi euh
depuis de nombreux mois merci alors qui
peut répondre là-dessus général oui je
peux répondre oui des dossiers ont été
ouverts pour des victimes françaises en
Ukraine euh par à la suite de de de la
décision du parquet national
antiterroriste et du pôle crime contre
l'humanité d'ouvrir ses enquêtes ce
n'est pas le cas et je crois que madame
dev vos l'a évoqué aujourd'hui
s'agissant du conflit Hamas Israël il y
a une enquête ouverte pour les faits du
7 octobre mais qui ont été qui a été
confié à des services spécialisés en
matière de terrorisme c'était le premier
temps et je pense que des plaintes sont
en cours d'analyse au parquet
pour notamment dans le cadre de victimes
potentiell franco-palestinienne voilà ce
que je peux vous dire dire en tout cas
nous ne traitons pas de dossier encore
ouvert aucun dossier n'est parvenu à
l'office central dans ce cadre
là merci la parole est à Éléonore carois
vice-présidente merci bonjour Merci moi
aussi d'être pr d'avoir été présent pour
échanger avec notre commission
aujourd'hui sur ce sujet si important
que la lutte contre l'impunité dans les
conflits modernes moi je souhaiterais
aborder une situation qu'on n pas encore
évoqué qui est celle du Nicaragua où le
président Daniel Ortega et son épouse
SIO mourillo ont instauré un pouvoir
dictatorial et violent en avril 2018 une
série de réformes de la sécurité sociale
ont entraîné des manifestations dans
tout le pays avec un bilan extrêmement
lourd près de 500 morts 4000 blessés et
plus de 1200 détentions arbitraire la
crise s'est accrue en 2021 dans le
contexte des dernières élections
présidentielles auquell le président
Ortega a été réélu pour son 4e mandat
consécutif avec la suppression de toute
concurrence électorale harcèlement
intimidation des candidats et des
opposants le groupe d'experts des droits
de l'homme des Nations Unies sur le
Nicaragua a conclu que de graves
violations et abus des droits de l'homme
ont été commis et continu de lêre en
soulignant les violations et les abus
perpétrés de manière généralisée malgré
les recommandations régulières du groupe
d'experts et de la communauté
internationale la situation ne
s'améliore pas et le pays s'est
progressivement isolé sur la scène
internationale ma question est quelle
est la limite de la définition du crime
contre l'humanité s'il reste impuni
quels sont les autres leviers pour
lutter contre l'impunité de ce type de
crime merci merci merci une minute 15
pour l'Amérique latine dont on parle
assez peu merci
Éléonore alors oui c'est c'est alors
comme le dit effectivement jislen c'est
pas une situation confirmée donc le CISR
n'est pas concerné pour vous répondre
sur la qualification de crime contre
l'humanité ce sont des crimes qui sont
commis dans le cadre d'attaque
généralisé et systématique à l'encontre
de la population civile donc pour
pouvoir les qualifier ainsi euh c'est
cela qu'il faut démontrer le caractère
généralisé le caractère systématique
contre la population civile alors il y a
pas de de procédure qui sont parvenus
jusque aux juridiction française euh je
crois que euh effectivement ça pourrait
être le cas hein dans l'absolu euh si
euh un dignitaire venait sur le
territoire français il pourrait y avoir
une plainte qui serait analysée alors je
sais pas ce qu'on en ferait mais ça
serait euh ça serait pas in congru ça
serait pas impossible euh par contre
simplement une précision les chefs
d'État en exercice devant les
juridictions nationales peuvent arguer
d'une immunité he des chefs d'État en
exercice ce qui n'est pas le cas devant
la Cour pénale internationale c'est
quand même la nuance et une limite donc
à la compétence universel par rapport à
ce qui se fait dans la
CPI merci euh le 4e orateur est Monsieur
Alexis jolie pour une
minute merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames générales la communauté
internationale est dotée de nombreuses
organisations d'innocents et visant à
prévenir les exactions contre les
minorités chrétiennes et religieuses
enfin ethniques pardon et religieus
pourtant depuis des décennies les
chrétiens subissent régulièrement des
persécutions allant jusqu'au nettoyage
ethnique d'un grand nombre de pays
d'Afrique du Moyen-Orient d'Asie
d'Amérique du Sud et ce la plupart du
temps dans le silence le plus total et
l'ONG porte ouverte d'après elle 360
millions de chrétiens ont vécu en 2023
dans un contexte de persécution et de
discrimination massive et là on parle
pas hein de voir son CV écarté par un
recruteur mais de devoir se cacher sous
peine d'emprisonnement de voir sa maison
brûlée ou d'être torturé voir massacré
avec toute sa famille donc le temps me
manque pour énoncer toutes les exs dont
les chrétiens ont été victimes et
continuent d'être les victimes un peu
partout mais je donnerai quand même un
seul chiffre il y a un sec un habitant
sur 4 du Moyen-Orient était chrétien
aujourd'hui c'est 1/ 30 et donc ma
question vient compéter celle de Madame
B je souhaite comprendre pourquoi le
silence général autour de cette
situation et pourquoi il est considéré
comme politiquement incorrect de mettre
ce sujet sur la table je vous remercie
merci alors les chrétiens à
nouveau je peux malheureusement vous
faire que la même réponse que celle que
j'ai faite à à Madame B il y a quelques
il y a quelques
minutes nous nous ne faisons que du
droit et que des enquêtes dont nous
sommes saisis et nous ferons au mieux de
nos capacités dans tous les dossiers qui
nous seront confiés quel que soit
l'origine des
victimes
merci j'ai encore deux orateurs
puisqu'il semble que R sou ne soit pas
là donc c'est frédériquesk pour une
minute s'il vous plaît merci madame la
Présidente mesdam général merci pour
votre présentation vous avez présenté la
création de tribunaloc ou encore la mise
en place de la cour pén internationale
qui participe à la à la recherche de
justice toutefois cette recherche
justice rencontre bien des obstacles
comme par exemple le d'extradition la
prescription ou la promulgation de lois
d'amnistie euh je voudrais revenir sur
le cas particulier de de la Biélorussie
où le bon le gouvernement dealexandre
Lukachenko mène une politique
autoritaire répressive depuis des années
à l'encontre de l'opposition mais aussi
s'est aussi rendu coupable de soutenir
la Russie dans l'évasion illégale du
territoire ukrainien et de déporter des
mineurs Ukrainiens sur le sol biélorusse
et par ailleurs monsieur Lukachenko
s'est accordé tout récemment le 4
janvier dernier ité avis contre toute
poursuite judiciaire dès lors dans ces
circonstances comment les instances
internationales et nationales vont-elles
pouvoir agir pour rendre la justice en
cas de transition démocratique et avec
ces lois qui sont votées dans dans ces
pays je vous
remercie et je vais faire une exception
à la règle en donnant la parole à
Frédéric petit qui est président du
groupe du groupe d'études
avOcatiOn vous avez un package de
Frédérique de modem et de Bélarus pour
finir moi je voulais vous je vis vous
revenir sur le sur un sujet beaucoup
plus d'abord quelque chose qui marche je
rappelle quand même à tous mes collègues
que Poutine n'a pas pu aller en Afrique
du Sud parce que sinon il aurait été
arrêté il y a des fois ça
marche je reviens sur quelque chose qui
me touche personnellement et qu'on a pas
trop abordé sur le la compétence
universelle je je parle de de
connaissance même d'amis Bélarus donc je
complète la question de de de mon
collègue
Frédéric qui sont exilés et qui sont
menacés de mort aujourd'hui ici dans
cette voilà et certains me parlent me
disent mais je voudrais faire jouer la
compétence universelle je sais que
certains essayent je je je je voudrais
savoir comment ça se passe ça a pas été
trop abordé c'est-à-dire que la présence
de la victime est là le le le crime est
encore en cours puisqueune menace de
mort c'est une menace de mort et comment
la compétence universelle se met en
œuvre est-ce que c'est vous comment ça
avance voilà je je suis je j'attends
votre réponse à ces précisions
éventuellement ça évidemment ça complte
la parole de mon collègue qui est aussi
au groupe
mer alors biellorusie que répondre juste
juste une précision par rapport
effectivement à la première question sur
la la Biélorussie qui serait complice de
crime commis par Poutine et qui font
l'objet du mandat d'arrêt hein contre la
ministre aussi qui était chargé de de
l'enfance mandat d'arrêt de la Cour
pénale internationale pour
spécifiquement la déportation des
enfants ukrainien la Cour pénale
internationale va être compétente et
c'est étonnant parce
que Poutine est quand même le chef
d'état d'un pays qui n'est pas parti au
Statut de Rome et pourquoi parce que les
faits sont commis sur le territoire
ukrainien sur des victimes ukrainiennes
qui Ukraine qui a reconnu la compétence
de la Cour pénale internationale et ça
date pas d'aujourd'hui puceque ça datait
d'avant le
conflit actuel et donc par définition
c'est un critère qui va permettre aussi
si
d'autres d'autres ressortissants
notamment biéloruses sont impliqués de
pouvoir aussi les inclure dans l'enquête
de la Cour pénale internationale donc il
y a une ouverture là-dedans si la Cour
détermine qu' a des responsabilités
autres s'agissant de la question que
vous posez par rapport à la compétence
universelle là forcément je suis
interpellé par la qualification des
faits hein de menace de mort qui ne
rentent pas euh dans les qualifications
de crimes internationaux et que
justement la présence des victimes sur
le territoire français ne va pas suffire
à entraîner la juridiction des la
juridiction la compétence des
juridictions françaises donc je pense
que là le l'obstacle euh serait là je je
termine en disant que c'est parfois le
cas dans le cadre de répression de la
population après les violences
électorales par exemple qui n'atteignent
pas un degré alors qu' sont très graves
mais pas un degré
d'intensité suffisant pour être qualifié
de crime contre l'humanité par exemple
et donc ça a été le cas dans un certain
nombre de pays au Gabon on a eu des
analyses et on a conclu que c'était des
crimes mais des crimes de droit commun
et qui du coup n'entraînai pas la
compétence universelle des juridictions
françaises merci beaucoup alors comme
plus aucun plus aucun orateur n'est
inscrit il me revient de dire quelques
mots de de conclusion et je demande aux
collègues de rester parce que comme je
l'ai dit à à 12h30 nous avons encore une
dernière formalité à faire euh donc
d'abord je voulais vous remercier euh
mesdames générales et puis rendre
hommage à votre action et à travers vous
aux femmes et aux hommes qui travaillent
tant dans la justice en tant que
magistrat juge et cetera à l'office qui
est plus discret mais dont on on mesure
le rôle important qu'il a et puis aussi
à à la Croix-Rouge au CICR madame et
puis je pense qu'on peut rendre hommage
à tous ceux qui dans l'ombre loin de la
lumière travaillent et et d'une certaine
façon apporte la voix de la France la
voix singulire de la France pour lutter
contre l'impunité deuxième point c'est
que je voudrais dire à tous les
collègues et et à ceux qui nous écoutent
c'est que notre parole compte notre
parole à nous parlementaires alors bien
sûr suivant les sensibilités notre
intérêt peut être plus ou moins fort
pour tel ou tel type de victime telle ou
telle religion tel ou tel groupe
ethnique telle ou telle nationalité mais
si on a autant parlé de droit c'est que
le droit est un outil pour mettre à
distance pour s'efforcer d'être précis
dans la référence au droit
international pour être sérieux et
fiable dans la collecte d'preuve et puis
en final permettre une sanction juste et
donc je je voudrais vraiment redire que
ce ce type de table ronde est important
et que nous avons aussi le devoir après
au-delà de d'aller plus
loin je note aussi la référence qui a
été faite plusieurs fois au devoir de
vigilance c'est un sujet sur lequel j'ai
travaillé plusieurs fois et le la mise
en place des nouveaux textes européens
sur le devoir de vigilance va nous
amener à avoir d'autres billets aussi
via les entreprises et les
sous-traitants des entreprises et les
sous-traitant et sous-traitant qui dans
la chaîne de valeur peuvent commettre
des violations vous l'avez dit mais
au-delà j'ai noté votre proposition
votre suggestion d'agir sur des verrous
restants en particulier mais pas que la
question de la résidence habituel ou de
ou de la présence ce que je vous propose
pour ne pas oututrepasser mes mes
prérogatives c'est que nous en parlions
euh au sein du bureau et pourquoi pas en
commission parce que je pense que cela
pourrait faire l'objet d'un travail plus
approfondi maintenant que nous sommes
éclairés par cette table ronde donc je
voudrais à nouveau remercier la qualité
et la bonne tenue globale ce qui n'est
pas gagné parce que on sait les les
sensibilités comme comme je l'ai rappelé